This episode of Your Mom's house is
brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that
provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
[inaudible]
yeah,
I'm on the road getting back into it.
Um, where am I going to
be? Budget stuff sold out.
I'll just tell you what isn't some
tickets left in Eugene, Oregon?
Uh,
the second show added in ball Sacramento
has some tickets also Fresno and
Bakersfield Park now. That's
right. Fort Myers, Florida. Um,
November 1st.
Jack me off.
Phil is going to be gone real soon.
That's two months away.
Um,
what else?
Come on. You Georgia.
Augusta. Wait, wait. Come on.
You is what the Augusta a guys come,
a guy comes on you disgust.
Disgust. Yeah. Uh, the added show
in Montclair, November 14, mom,
Claire,
that one's obvious.
Obviously the second one is sold
out and the third show was added in.
Fill her up Delphia November 17th so
you can get tickets to the late show.
Um, Friday and Saturday
are basically gone. Okay.
So that's that.
Christina,
why don't you show us
how those big tits Fart?
Yeah, I sure. Well, Tom,
uh, a little, uh, uh,
awake all night. Breastfeeding
is such a gift to your child.
It is November 24th at the House of Blues.
How's it brews in San Diego,
California, California.
Those take us are moving fast. It's
a, it's, it's, it's pretty exciting.
And then the 7th of December,
fill her up Delfia and then
December 8th in Ju Dork titties,
I've added a site could show at
the Gramercy theater 10:30 PM show.
Grab those tickets. Now all these things
are moving very quickly and it's all,
it's so far out there. They're
selling. So get them now,
Christina P on blind,
she probably mentioned my website.
For those who don't
know for those tickets,
[inaudible] dot com go to the core
page or you even a professional in show
business.
And I've mentioned it on other episodes.
If you go to that tour
and you'll see the prompt
to enter your email,
you can get advanced notice about some
shows that wink wink might be coming up
pretty soon. It might be
a big announcement. Yeah.
You know,
if you wanted to shop on Amazon,
there's all kinds of ways you can do that.
Cool.
Go to people's websites.
I cast websites like your mom's house.
Yup. Podcast gas.com. And it's
something that you could do.
You could and you could click on a banner
that looks like an Amazon banner and
do your show. But I'll just take
another poop right here soon. Um,
all right,
well we got that out of the way.
You know where you're going to see us
live. Uh, we thank our sponsors. Now.
Are you ready to start the show?
Jamie? Ready? I am ready. Gene here.
Here you go. Oh, make sure this.
Yay It.
Eh,
here we go.
Y'All got that Nigga. Fuck them John
or whatever the fuck his name is.
Cause most of the Niggas
I'm here talking about him.
Hey one of these niggas asked him that
made a status like y'all so perfect.
Oh God ain't no raw.
We get a Nigga getting his ass,
a motherfucking females and I ain't saying
that cause I eat Niggas as I'm saying
it because it is what it is.
Don't bring in
well go to your mom's house.
I liked this girl. It's a very
divisive issue in our nation. Where,
I mean this has come up quite a bit here.
Do you think Donald Trump
gets his ass eaten? I don't
think so. I don't think reg,
I don't think the line you guys like,
yeah,
let me eat your yourself now with
millennia. She's the bottom bitch.
It's happened before.
I think he demands and I feel like
he would be like get in there though.
I think he's probably like
that's a minus sissy stuff or so.
Oh cause he's of that generation
that's like but by mail, by holy names,
nothing needs to happen there. Do
you think that guys, your dad's age,
a lady butts or even that's considerably
not, yeah, they're probably like no,
that's gross.
You don't need to do it is yeah,
I'm going to side with them on that.
Nothing Nigga you fingers and Annee de
questionable my Nigga buck drill need to
do as did you suck his dick?
You licking his bowl.
You might as well eat that ass.
That's true. That is kind of point
a hundred percent sure God blessing.
There's a lot of that.
Yeah. And I'll just eat niggas acid
so don't be like punch a bitch. No,
cause I asked him where I'd
be like she can't, what's up?
Can I eat your last cause I like
him all on his case or whatever.
Like he ain't the only Nigga I like
in his motherfucking ass. Aight.
I thought she said she didn't eat ass
before. I know she does. Oh I hear you.
I feel like she was making,
she was clowning on people
that are, you know, saying like
no and making fun of it. Gotcha.
I think it's in reference to obviously
like some story of some celebrity or
someone, I don't know what it's
in reference to, but you know,
making a good point, very divisive
issue in our nation today in our nation.
Is it considered homosexual?
Of course not getting hit. Why
would that be homeless? No,
it's okay. Well she's telling you that
there's lines to the scrum. So legging.
The scram is not, well, she's
like, if you like extra things,
inserting a finger in your,
in your be hole,
punch a beach.
No,
but she's saying that if he likes
something inserted in his be halls or your
questionable, then you're on the,
you're kind of gay adjacent. Yeah.
Which I also think is funny thing.
I don't think if you'd like something
inserted or you're gay excited if it's a
dick than you are.
If you're like,
I like Dick's coming up in my ass,
then you're probably gay. True. Fake.
What about, okay, well let's
follow this logic train. Okay.
What about a Dildo or a woman wearing
a strap on? Is that gay? I mean,
that feels more gay
adjacent. I, I've, you know,
it's never occurred to me that
that would be a reality that,
uh,
would partake and be like,
well you strap a dick on it. But
I mean, but I got the guy isn't,
I guess a hundred percent necessarily
gay, but he's definitely, once he wants,
he wants the virtual reality ride for
sure. You know, cause it, but then again,
it's not attached to a dude.
Right. That's a key ingredient.
But then again it is a dick. It's kind of
like the traffic in a woman. Yeah. Yeah.
But see like,
you know,
there's always been that argument about
a man that's with a transsexual woman,
you know? I mean he doesn't
like a straight up other men.
He likes a man with tits.
Yeah.
And but like the presentation of a woman,
it's complicated. Confusing. It's not,
it's not straight up black and white
because some guys are really into that,
you know, the, they want
the aesthetic of a female.
So female looking face, female
looking, you know, body,
except genitals that are not, so
that's, that's pretty complicated.
So that this is not that far.
This is, this is like what I mean,
I don't even think that that should
be part of this conversation. Right.
Like somebody, not somebody being like,
I like my ass eat and they're like,
you gay. No, no, no.
That's crazy. That's silly.
I mean this is really God Burt special.
Are you playing
the most racist? Yeah. I don't
think that's going either. And I,
and again a very polarizing, what's
what sort of course not. Oh yeah.
Yeah it's, you know it's, it's the thing,
it's, it's a, I don't think it's gay.
I think having, like you said, I
wouldn't even say like a strap ons gay.
I would think that as long as it's, if
it's attached to a dude then you're gay.
Right? Right. Yeah. It's clear cut.
But then what is a dude in these non
Barrett Binary Times? Interesting point.
I mean are we being,
what's the word? Binaries?
Just probably if we write,
we're old,
we're binary shaming older.
I mean let's see what else you said.
Oh lot of y'all niggas like in y'all ass.
Hey I didn't ate a few y'all niggas
acid so I know for sure you feel me and,
and I never just eat it Nigga ass niggas
be asking me or whatever like or I
asked him so in a Nigga say he is,
oh I ain't never just sneaky.
He's and the guests like sucking his
dick and then hurry up and lick his ass.
Hell Nah Nigga cause your
body to go wash that thing.
Oh she doesn't just do it in prompt
to know saying you gotta be clean.
So she'll give him a heads
up like hey I'm Gunna,
I'm Gunna let get and then you take
a shower. What about a wet wipe?
Do you think that's enough or pinch?
But I mean it's better.
It's really better to really get
in there and scrub I think. Yeah.
I mean yeah that's pretty dirty area.
Yeah.
Y'all stay here really like really?
Oh his heels though.
Like y'all on that met life shitting
on him cause he like he he got his ass
eight or whatever like rather
he liked that shit or not.
He came lie that she feel good cause I
ain't got my ass ate a lot of times and
that shit feel good.
Crazy talk this person right.
That's why you got a bum bump on your lip.
You know it actually brings a no,
I'm never going to eat your scrump.
Just so you know.
Interesting. Interesting.
Somebody actually wrote in this message,
maybe you can read it. Nope, just read it.
It says all on Mommy's a huge fan of
the podcast and love listening to it.
I have a big problem.
My husband and I have been together for
almost seven years and I've never seen
his butthole. You're lucky I feel
because he has seen all of me,
but hauling all that I deserve to see his,
I've asked him repeatedly to show me
his brown eye and even went as far as to
set up mirrors in places
to catch a glimpse.
I fear I might die before ever seeing
it. So my question is, Christina,
have you seen Tom's butthole and what do
you recommend I do to see my husband's
by hall? Thanks for taking time to read.
Love you guys. Keep high and tight.
The butthole investigator, Natalie.
Uh, I just saw your butt hole.
I saw Tom that whole like yesterday.
You did? Yeah, dude, we were um,
we were just playing and you bend over
and spread. Remember, how are we doing?
And you kind of,
it's like in the last 72
hours I've seen your ass hole.
It's not pretty.
It's very hairy and dark and
scary. It's kind of like, um,
the upside down a stranger
things. Yeah. Like Wah,
it's all dark and mysterious
and, and um, toxic,
toxic. You feel sad when you see
it. Jesus. Yeah. Stuff like that.
That's not true. Uh, how do I, you know,
here's what you can do to get your
boyfriend to show you or as a husband,
I can't remember, uh, play a
little game called stripper. Yeah.
You know that's true.
Yeah.
Remove. Oh yeah, we're, I, yeah,
I slapped my hands on my butt and then I
run them down the back of my legs and I
bend down like I'm doing
a hot stripper dance.
So you may want to encourage
him. You start, you go, hey,
you want to see my stripper dance?
And then you do it and you
spread your cheeks and then go,
now you do it and then make
him do what you just did. Yeah.
It's pretty good idea.
But you don't want to see it.
A man in that position is hideous.
Cause his twig and berries or mashed,
it's not, I mean, it's not
going to turn her on. No.
But she'll get to see what she wants to
see. I think she might regret seeing it.
Yeah. Why do you want to see it? But
again, what would it take for you to eat?
Like that girl saying, you know, right.
No, it's never going to happen. It's
just not for me in this lifetime. I mean,
what if it's something I need though.
You don't.
We've been together a million years.
You know, I don't need it. No,
you don't need it. You've
got, you've gone this far.
I know, but I mean, I need
it. I need that scrum meeting.
I need it. I mean nasty as hell, Tom.
Um,
yeah.
No it's not. It's not on
the table right now. I know.
I'm just lucky to get my hygiene back.
You know,
I have my six week checkup after having
my badge blasted through childbirth and
we got the green light. I know. And
let's just start there. You know,
you're talking to like
varsity level stuff, man.
We need to get back into
just regular old entrance
courses and know, so
tired as you are too. I'm,
I made so much fitness last month,
people don't know this on the show,
but I go to this gym where we
were a telemetry strap. Okay.
And,
um,
and that what happens is it assigns
points based on your heart rate, you know,
in a workout. So if you
have it spike a lot, um,
you're getting higher points.
And I was working at a bunch
at the beginning of the
month and they're like, oh,
you're number one. I was
like, oh, that's great.
And then the guy at the gym that
my trainer would text me, Oh,
you're number three. I was like,
fuck. I started to get mad about it,
you know?
Yeah.
So then it just kept going and going
and then at the end there I kind of went
crazy.
Right?
Yeah. Yeah. It's a mental
problem. I mean, look,
I'm concerned with feeding our newborn.
I don't sleep either in the
night I wake up every few hours.
The dog had diarrhea last night. I was up
and now dealing with that. But you know,
you got your problems too. Like if you
can beat this stranger. Yeah. With points,
with points for your workouts.
So it sounds like you're mocking.
No, no, no. I think it's, you know,
you're tired and you gotta work out a
lot to beat this lady and that doesn't
know that I'm competing with her,
which is even cooler. Yeah, yeah. Yeah.
That's pretty interesting.
So that last day I did three workouts.
That's fun.
I still feel it. I feel it today.
Three days later. Yeah. Uh,
yeah. You going to do this
again in September? No. 10
I'm just going to do normal.
No, I mean, I'm, I'm going to do it again,
but now that I did it, I made number one.
I'm like, cool. Just be, uh, be active.
I don't have to be number one. Well,
if you were to compete with her,
again, I suggest the scrabble method.
If you've ever played
scrabble with a friend. Yeah.
The key is to get a ton of
points at the top of the game.
Like when you play the electronic version
and you get that assistant thing to
help you. Yeah. Just get away. You gotta
stack the points at the top of the game.
Yeah. No, it helps in play. Catch
up. Yeah. Can I let that bitch what,
what does she do that so fishy goes. So
what happens is she works out at the gym.
Yeah.
Set my gym is a small gym that has like
a one on one and you can do small group
trainings.
You can go with like three friends and
be like train us together or you could do
one on one. It's small and
it's just personal training.
Sometimes you could do like
weightlifting core stuff. Um,
boxing.
There's like some martial arts trainers
there so you can do kickboxing and
that's it. This lady goes there, does
her workouts with one of the trainers.
In addition to that, she also
goes to spin class a lot. Oh,
what a spin class gets you,
your heart rate really jacked up.
So that's how she kills it with points.
Okay.
Yeah. What's interesting about this,
and I've never done soul cycle,
but people love it and I, and
I'm like, and they pay a fortune.
I hear it's very expensive. Yeah. It's
like, um, it's a stationary bicycle,
but with a lot of people. Right. And
you just listened to like cool music.
Is that gas? I've never, I've never
got it. I hear it's fantastic. Yeah.
I mean the whole thing is in or that
environment supposed to help you write,
write, write, write, write the music.
It's a real positive coach. Gotcha.
There's also people all around,
you're doing the same thing and I think
you like stand up on the bicycle and
then you sit down, you know, like make it
really crazy. Damn. That's hard as fuck.
It's pretty hard. Hardcore
how much you lose weight
faster. And that, um, you know,
we were discussing a lot
a forest and Jenny. Yeah.
Whether she's a gutter slot and you know,
abuse this man of somewhat,
uh,
restricted intellectual ability.
Right. Well, let, the debate was,
is it ethical or should you
date the mentally challenged?
Right. Which clearly forest is not,
not mentally challenge, right? I mean,
yeah, we don't know what his level pretty
functioning and he's high functioning,
but he's not a regular
guy. Right. And he's not
just a normal dude is like, hey,
what's up mom? And Blah Blah. I live,
I like chocolate. He could do
standup comedy though. Yeah,
he could probably pull off. There's
a few comments. He sounds just,
yeah. Um, so anyway, this is,
um, the messages that came in. Hey,
mommy's in Forrest Gump.
Jenny was a calm dog with a heart of
gold who tried to help forest out.
The only way she knew how early in
the film when she snuck into her,
she snuck him into her dorm dorm room. So
we get a handful of hungry tits. Right.
Until he blew his snot and his
dungarees she didn't have to do that.
Her Final Act of bravery was to break him
off some posts while she's still still
had a post to give. No one else was,
there was no tender for tards today.
Forget about the south in the 60s.
Also,
him being a single father ups his chances
of pounding some pissed flaps by a
thousand percent Jenny
truly selfless, rob. Huh.
That's an interesting twist
on this ever growing a debate.
Another important debate in America today
is whether or not Jenny abused forests
right to jiff him helped
him. I mean, I can see,
I feel like this is a spin
on reality from rob, but um,
that's an interesting point.
Over the last,
maybe Jenny was truly giving and just
this is the only way she knew how to give.
She contracted HIV because they
had a biker gang bangs. Right.
She was doing gang bangs on her nationwide
dick to her before she ran into us
before or after she became the first
lady of the United States of America.
Well before. Yeah. No. Yeah. This is
before her it. Yeah, that's right.
I cannot wait to see.
By the way,
guess what we fucked up last
night when we were like, oh,
what are we going to watch Ozark
Susan tease out with her? Fuck. Fuck.
God dammit.
I love that fucking
well, I know we're in a kind of a show
Lala right now. We got our Ozark back.
We've been watching the Shahs
of sunset on Bravo. Silly.
It's kind of mindless fun. Oh my God.
I didn't have chance to set this up.
Better Call Saul. I was watching
the, I wonder if I could bring it up.
I was watching better call Saul is even
better this season. It's fantastic.
I fucking love that show,
that serial killer thing last night.
I know I got to fall asleep to that again.
Thanks.
And it was really a dark
one too. It was like, um,
how to tell if your kid is
a serial killer. I overheard
that. You miss something.
That's fine when you're a mom of two boys.
I was so when they were first
explaining all the different,
you know,
variables that might lead someone to be
this way and they're talking about uh,
you know,
the
CT scans they run and how their
brains are different. Well yeah,
but then they got to a
part, I was like, Ooh,
Christina might like this parcel.
Christine might kind of flip out at this
part and I didn't get a chance to set
it up and I think I can play it for
you here. Hold on. Let me see. Yeah,
this just came out. What's
the show called? It's called
inside the criminal mind.
Great.
Just what I was hoping to
hear about Christina. Oh Shit.
You're going to like that
for them.
This area was physically shrunken by
18% this could account for why they can
kill without guilt or
remorse. Oh, hold on.
Just give it a second. Oh, I know. I know.
Criminologists have also found another
possible biological predictor of Danish
antisocial behavior, low
resting heart rate. Oh my God.
They theorize that those with low rates
don't feel fear as strongly as others.
Oh my God,
that's you.
They may be more violent and take physical
risks because they are less fearful
of the consequences
is that life may feel a bit dull
to people with low heart rates,
so that's excitement and
crazy intense stimulation.
Oh my God,
this is you to a tease over
people that don't know.
I have an incredibly low sitting heart
rate because, well, I don't know,
but a few years ago it was so stunning
to my general physician that he sent me
to Cedars Imaging Institute
and the Cardiac Center and
they ran a bunch of tests
for a couple of days and at
the end they were like, Huh,
you just have a low heart rate.
Like there was no diagnosis? No,
I'm saying for what
causes the low heart rate.
No, and even we had the life insurance
lady come and she took your blood pressure
and she was like, wow, you have
a really low resting heart rate.
It a serial killer husband.
I even have it
getting that old old bit about the
first time my doctor checked it out,
he was like,
your heart rate is like a
Olympic marathon running low.
I was like, yeah, it's pretty low.
And he was like, why? I'm like,
because I run a lot, I'm sure.
Um, no, but you know in my,
at my real deepest rest of the state,
it's in the low forties
sometimes in the thirties
you've listened to your heartbeat before.
Like, I'll have my head on your chest,
go, go, go.
Anyways, I started to laugh
so hard at those lights. Why
you? You are who you are,
you know? I do think that your
low resting. Okay. For instance,
I've taken 'em a pill that slows
down my heart a little bit.
I forget what it's called.
Yeah. Like many, many years ago,
and I used to perform on it and couldn't
because it would slow me down so much
and it was like Bra, but that's how
you are where I'm like, oh my God,
Tom, you sold out the Wilbur. Isn't this
the most exciting thing? And you're like,
yeah, that's great. And you kind of
sighed a loud noise like, hey guys,
like you totally are.
It totally mellows you.
Oh, also I overheard the
children caffeine all the time.
Oh
yeah, you're, you're almost dead. So
they say that the children of the serial
killers has children. They light fires.
Yeah. Bed wetters Oh, bad. Wetters
and animal harmers now did it,
you kill a Bald Eagle?
No,
I did kill an endangered.
A woodpecker. Okay. But
it was not chat for my,
it wasn't for my own amusement.
It wasn't my, it was,
it was because my dad wanted me to,
I also wasn't like a kid torturing it.
It was a bird that was fucking up our
house and he was like, shoot that.
I never tortured animals. That
is actually the one, you know,
they discredited that.
They're saying that that was
what they used to tell people,
so what do they tell you now? How do you
know your kids is much more complicated?
But in like that,
that was actually very dangerous because
in the fifties or sixties when they
were telling people that a lot, you
know, you have these parents being like,
my kid pissed his pants
and he lit a match.
Oh Hey, I played with fire.
Well, fire is fascinating. Yeah.
I'm not saying that.
My parents were,
I might say my dad was negligent when
he would drink and fall asleep and I got
to play with the fireplace at
the age of seven or eight. Um,
when you get to play with a
little bit of fire, come on.
I used to throw all kinds of shit
in the fireplace. But anyways,
yeah, that's clearly you're the mark of a
real associate star. I was like, Oh shit.
They're like low heart rate.
I wonder what that really is for you.
What this low heart rate,
this low resting,
all those tests,
like at the one of the finest medical
institutions, they were just like,
you have an effective heart.
You know what's so funny is that you
really don't have like a sense of urgency.
I've never seen you like panicked and
hurried even in times when you should be
like, I've never seen you like we've got,
you know, like me, like I'm a Jack Rabbit.
I wake up and I'm like,
you're not like that at all.
It takes you a long time to wind up
and then like, you know what I mean?
I Dunno if I've never done urgency.
I've never seen you like
panicked and running, running.
You said even when you should be like
free. Like for instance, you know,
missing airplanes. Have you ever,
I just don't see you doing that.
I remember one time we were connecting
for Hawaii and you and I had to get to
the thing and like that. You know what
I mean? And I'm not really a runner.
You're just kinda like,
all right, we'll get there.
Maybe that's cause you're a low
resting heart way. Right. I Dunno.
Maybe I don't see myself being late for
a lot of flights, so either, you know,
I'm always on time. It
was a connection. We,
it was for our vacation and it was
like the airport was really fucked up.
It was a Honolulu and we had to
get to learn and they're like,
you playing takes off in 15 minutes,
but it's on the other side of the airport
and we had to like book ass to get to
this 10 hour. She's like, don't worry
about it. No, you are. You are behind me.
Like 20 steps and I was
running ahead of you. Yeah.
Trying to think what, I'm trying to think
of times I've seen you like a hurried.
You generally like, no, I dunno.
It's you're lucky. It's good.
I don't see myself. Yeah. I mean I'm
definitely not a panic. The person. No,
that's me. That's I'm high anxiety
and I tend to panic more. Definitely.
You need a good balance.
Yeah. Good balance. Anyways,
talk about your dumps.
Let's talk about our dumps.
It's been so crazy. Crazy. Yeah.
I'm really,
it's been quite an active,
my valve has been active
for the last few weeks.
We've been eating Paleo
these last few weeks and man,
the browns are just ridiculous.
It's just all these nutrients.
Everything's clean,
you know,
clean eating and it's a minimum
three a day. But here's the thing.
No slaps.
No, it's not sloppy. [inaudible]
they're just like, yeah, you're healthy.
And the glide ride their gliders.
And I think that's been the
key to my hemorrhoid relief.
I don't have hemorrhoids anymore.
You're eating great. Yeah.
I'm not to push the Brown.
Isn't it nice just slides right down three
times a day? No, I go on. I go, no, no.
I go in the morning. Once in
the morning, but it's just easy.
Like I just sit down in the
brown just slides down. Huh?
Multiples. I know. It's just
unbelief and they're normal.
They're like full normal. I'm
like, how is there this fives? No,
like fours, three for three
and a half, four, five.
Is Lute looser on the Bristol stool
chart? These are like healthy. No,
but you're like,
how is there this much inside of me?
I know.
And then I like to weigh myself before
and after just to see how it's a really
neat,
always weigh yourself after a doubt.
Oh my God. I have something
so amazing. Um, I've,
this guy has sent in,
um,
prank calls before Fort Simpson and he,
uh, he sent one here. Um, the talent,
I tell you if he's so good,
Fort Simpson
tell you that prank calls and stuff.
Um, it's so hard. Like how do they,
how do you prepare that stuff? How
do you know? Do you know what I mean?
When the person says something
in the moment and you're like,
I have to find the button to put like
how the fuck do you do that so fast?
This is
not a simple set up.
The ones that he does elaborate.
So I mean, it's really dedicated.
It's like writing a song. I know. And
you can listen to his a prank call album.
Um,
it's at Fort simpson.bandcamp.com.
He's got a bunch of calls on
there in addition to some,
um, why mh one. So here is
this latest one. Holy Shit.
And that thing is free. By the way,
I'm going to mute this because the, uh,
the link like, yeah. Yeah.
This, this is so good.
I realized that we've
sometimes it with interruption,
they should be uninterrupted.
So I'll mute our lines
and you can hear this.
Bart Simpson and this would call
uses top dog, uh, my dad and uh,
I'll just let it play.
Enjoy.
Hey Man,
what's your question there? Are you
guys use over there for your truck nuts?
I'm not following you,
but see as all hear your thing and uh,
polysulfide Oh,
is that good to put on skin?
You know, I couldn't tell you cause
I don't do that. Yep. You know,
I don't know what they're made out of.
Let me see if it even tells me
it my computer system. Ah, but,
but those truck nuts, I
couldn't, you know, it's hard
to say, but let's see here.
I'm hearing my own garage trying to
make my custom truck nuts and my daddy's
about to pass away.
He don't got too much longer live.
It's always been a big fan of truck
nuts and I figured the best way to
commemorate him.
Answer.
Remember what an awesome man he was
was just get a nice cast of his balls.
Right? Well, I'm not sure.
Joe's speakerphone.
I got my hands full over here.
This is my dad talk though.
Hey Buddy, how you doing?
I'm doing a fantastic,
can I bring up a question
here that I have on my mind?
G boobs are really gigantic.
If you Google g boobs,
we'll find some big books.
Okay.
There's anything Monday,
large store bee gees size sloppers.
What was it
dad did she fart?
This is another bad
smells. Terrible. We all have our
own fingerprint in the intestines.
Yep.
Hey Daddy,
remember that time you took a dump on top
of that shit pile in the backyard or I
remember that.
There you go.
That's an 18 wheeler Jill there.
Me and my dad have a have a shit
pile going all the back yard.
We had to go for past year now.
Yeah, it was gigantic.
Well that's why they make,
those are newer things that scoop them up.
Then you get,
then you got one of those loans.
Are they causing little wagons that
they use the haul that shit away?
Oh,
say that again.
I can't help it. My just, mine's
always spontaneous. Spur of the moment.
His balls are hanging through the heavy.
They're a big bowl of plaster.
Well that's one way of hanging around
town. Oh, it's an interesting spot.
Uh, polyurethane is, but it says
they,
why you believe in luck yet since ever
is a health these truck nuts work out.
I think I'm all pursued
making little one for women.
You'd be the first
women drive trucks too. Your miles will
hit both sides of the market, you know?
Yeah. I don't know how you're
going to make those for that,
but that'd be a good one.
Yeah.
I'm thinking about doing
truck cuts for ladies.
Start making truck
Lavia from our grandmas.
Well that's how you're
going to have to make the,
push the balls and make that work.
Thanks for all the help that are booked.
You guys have a good one.
Oh my God. That was really
good. Bart Simpson. I love that.
He um, he got that breathing
joke in there. Just the way I
try. You also got the guy laughing
and it did top talk laugh.
So they had like dad laughing
together at like dad jokes
the victim laughs. Oh, so dumb.
So good. He has another one that I,
I'm saving for next week, but uh,
another incredible one that
he made. Pretty funny. Yeah.
Really good. Thank you.
Fart Simpson. Um, go to, like I said,
Fart simpson.com,
or excuse me,
Fart Simpson's dot bandcamp.com and
you can listen to his prank calls.
Very, very good stuff in d gene. Uh,
it looks like people are
continuing to make FTC or Gtd.
Fgd Rdt. No, that'd be our TV.
This is the wrong graphic.
Somebody screwed up. Oh,
she tea RTD. That
doesn't seem right. Yeah.
Other people have submitted their guesses.
Fake Guy tits really teased dicks.
The flaming gay tinks ride.
Tremendous.
That's from a proud female fan rate.
Forrest Gump.
The rape to discuss Justin famish
get Thomas Rectum Troy delicious.
Steve and feels great.
Remove Phil's field.
Great tits removed that denim.
Jason, the mystery continues.
No one has been able to solve
what that standard JT RTD means.
And it's open to interpretation.
It is open to interpretation. Um,
real quick gene, oh, a couple people, um,
wanted clarity on a couple of
things here, um, that we can get to.
One was,
uh,
some people had some blow back on our
fat shaming and I just want it to be
clear. I thought it was clear. So,
but sometimes you got to hold people's
hands through a conversations when they
don't understand like what parts serious,
what parts of joke. I think what,
you know, at least what I was
trying to say was that a, um,
I don't think you should just obviously
ever just go harass somebody for their
weight. No, I was saying that
fat shaming was effective,
but I also embraced it, you know?
Yeah. Um, the other thing was like,
some people were like, yeah, but, uh,
are you trying to say that like
you're not fat? So they know I'm,
I've always said that
I'm still fat and that I,
but I'm actively working on it,
so I, I try to eat healthier.
I obviously exercise all
the time. And for me, um,
I don't reject fat shaming because I
had an experience with it now that I do
think you should, you know,
you shouldn't, like I said,
attack somebody for being fat.
I'm just of the mindset
that is not good to be fat.
Don't act like it's a positive
thing. And you know, if you want,
if you're looking for a tactic
that may or may not work for you,
I enjoyed fat shaming.
It works for you as a fantastic go out
and like fat shame people all over the
place.
No, I would ask you, and I don't
advocate know, shitting on people.
Oh, it's not that. I think first of all,
I'm overweight now too. I just had a baby,
so I'm fat shaming myself
every day to get it back down.
You mean we don't do it on the Shawl Tan,
but it's all we talk about with
ourselves is just like, fuck
yeah.
Well here's why I personally don't
think it should be celebrated to be
overweight because being overweight is
not a healthy option. Yeah, that's true.
So, for instance, um,
I know they have like magazine covers now
a cosmopolitan has a really overweight
model on there and it's like celebrate,
like she's obese and that's not,
I don't think that that's,
yeah, I understand curvy normal
yet. Got It. Got It. Good. Uh,
but I don't think as a lifestyle
that that should be encouraged. Yeah.
I would say that. But should we actively
share on people know, dude, of course not.
Yeah. No, I don't think it
should be celebrated. Like, uh,
you're clearly embracing an
unhealthy lifestyle. Good for you.
Like I don't think that's cool.
No. And I don't, I don't either.
So it's like I don't advocate, um,
don't harass people just
because they're fat. No,
but what I'm saying is like,
when people write off fat shaming as a
horrible thing to do, I'm like, yeah,
I don't think so.
And the reason I said I don't think so
is because I've experienced it and I
actually feel like it was
a pretty good motivator.
Yeah.
Some of the best thing that sometimes
the best thing that can happen to you is
one, a family member or a friend. He's
like, dude, you need to, you need to ring.
I'll tell you the difference.
When I was much younger and fat and,
uh, like I told you, Latins are like this,
and I would go to Peru and they
would fat shaming. I would reject it.
I would be like, fuck, I would, you know,
I wouldn't embrace it. Yeah, I would.
But I also think that I was being very
much in denial at that time. Yeah.
I was in denial. They were telling me, you
need to lose weight. And I was like, no,
I don't fuck them, you know, and that,
but the truth is they were right.
I did need to lose weight because being
heavier contributes to heart disease to
a whole host of unhealthy and
denial's a strong, strong thing.
So that was like, that was kind
of, I dunno for me, uh, uh,
kind of a lesson. No, just
growing in life. When,
when it was brought to my attention 15
years later, I was like, yeah, yeah,
they're right. You know, let's look up
what being overweight does to your body.
I know. I think we, we, we don't
need to, I think we all get that.
It's probably bad for everything.
You know, it's, it's bad.
It's bad for your cardiovascular
system. It's, it's, you know,
even my knees when I was,
I'm horse joints pain that
people experience in their back,
ankles, knee, all, all that can be related
to being overweight. It's cholesterol.
Yeah, of course. No,
there's, there's nothing.
You don't think that's just helps you
survive an overdose. That's it. That's the
Chris severe car accident.
There's a TV show we watch being,
being overweight saved my life on
TLC and this lady was like, well,
because I had 50 extra pounds on me.
The seatbelt like didn't cut through me
basically. And there's another good one,
like, so there's the possibility that
you don't wear a seatbelt when you drive.
And a, you might live through a
car accident instead of being,
instead of being hurled out of the car,
you might get wedged in it.
So there's the other big plus. All
right, so that's that. The other one, uh,
for some of you dumb dumbs is,
uh,
so many fucking idiots is a,
the Louis CK concert.
Really listen to what you say,
listen to what they want to hear.
And I've already experienced it many times
when they take things out of context,
it's like, you know, like when we bring
up other people, other celebrities,
and they're like,
why are you comparing the two?
It's like we're talking about what
has happened for the last year,
other celebrities and the differences
between what they're accused of.
We were probably one of the most
vocal people about the fact that it's
ridiculous to come to actually mention
him as someone that you would compare
what they did. Uh, uh,
Louie did with like what Harvey Weinstein
or Kevin Spacey did mentioning them in
the same breath as like, hey, these
guys are all abusers is not fair.
It's rich, ridiculous, different
shades of gray of course.
So we can't make it equal.
What you can talk guide as
it's their fucking, yeah,
you can talk about entertainers and
like this guy did this, this guy that.
But that doesn't mean we're saying what
he did was equal to what this guy did.
I mean it obviously isn't and I think
the people who think it's okay to equate
them are actually really doing
harm to that whole movement
by saying that like what he did is the
same and you should treat those guys the
same. It's really not. We're
talking about like violence,
sexual crimes versus his perversion cause.
I think the more specific we can get
in terms of defining those gray areas,
that makes the movement way more
lasting way. More of an impact.
If you can start really getting into the
legal nitty gritty of it and being like,
well what is it that Louis C k? I said,
well let's, let's get into it man.
Let's define it. And that way the
next time it happens to a woman,
we can really go after the motherfucker,
right? They're not all the same,
of course are not the same.
And it's like peep.
Some people were like thought
like you're serious about,
he should move to friends. Like do you
really need to be explained the that part,
but you're not being serious about that.
He should move to France. Yeah. No,
I think the, there's two different issues
that we discussed on this show. Right?
There's those levels of seriousness
of what this person has done.
We weren't talking about that last week.
We're talking about is the PR here. Yeah.
I mean that was my,
like I'm somebody who we're not even
getting into what's the evil of it.
I'm somebody who has always been like,
I'll just say like I've
been a huge fan of his,
a big admirer of his ability
and talent. Like he's, to me,
one of the greatest, you
know, and when he did,
when he came out and did what he did
and you know, had to, to go away,
it made sense to me.
I always thought there's a path to
redemption for him. Right. Like that.
That to me it was like, that makes
sense. What he did was a bad swing.
It is come backable.
That's what it is.
And Cosby not come back up again,
come back, you're gone. So I'm like,
that makes sense. He's going away.
There is a path to redemption.
And to me the surprising thing
was not that he did stand up,
it's that he managed the optics so poorly.
To me,
that's the part that stood out.
It's just that I go,
this is a really smart guy on top of being
a really talented guy and when you're
really smart and really
talented and really influential,
there's a higher standard for you.
It's just the way it is,
whether you like it or not.
It's just the way it is.
For him to get onstage after this
break in this climate, in this time,
and be like, no statement,
no addressing things,
no like donation,
no own op ed piece about it.
That to me was just a lot of just like
what, you're not going to do any of those?
That seems like PR 101 so
that's the part that to me,
you stood out and that is a
discussion we had last week.
It's more about the startling
lack of awareness. Yeah.
Social climate and being like,
I'm just going to do this.
Let's talk about cookies and
candy and like, Whoa Bro,
you guys that don't get that by the way
are equally like as out of out of touch
with what's going.
Like you seem that out of out of touch,
you seem that disconnected and you're
actually, if you're a huge fan of his,
you're doing a him more
harm by being like,
so what you still just to like,
because you're actually fueling the fire
of the blow back of the people who are
like never again.
You're making that grow when you're like,
so it didn't do anything and I help him.
First of all,
it hasn't been positively received in
our community from what I gather. No,
the p the press has been really bad on it.
Um,
it just shows a lack of awareness and
it does show kind of an obliviousness to
the culture, to the climate
is when I'm saying of course,
regardless of whether or not you think
it's what he did is wrong or how wrong or
shitty do Stan who get like
as somebody like I remain,
I remain a big fan of course.
And I'll tell you all I hope that he
does is digest what's currently going on
and take those steps now so that he can
go back with like having put forth a
huge effort and said like,
you know,
I checked all the boxes so that people
who are fans go see like, you know,
you're a good guy.
Yeah.
I took all the steps and I think
that's what Americans love.
They love an apology. They love and
they love a come to Jesus and apology.
They love to think that you're a good guy.
Yes. So if you know this about America,
yeah. Give them, take a
page of the Michael Vick.
Vick was like, yes, he went to prison.
He could have come out of prison,
like suck my practic for life.
And instead he like,
he partnered with the humane
society, you know, he um, he made it,
he made donations. He filed for, I
forget whether it's seven or chapter,
whatever one where instead of
like doing a way with his debts,
he made it so that he had to pay
back his debts almost in full.
You know, and it's like, it's
like why is that important?
It just makes people go like,
oh, you're not a piece of shit.
Like he did it for himself,
but he also did it so that people go like,
you know what? You did a horrible
thing. But like you're a pretty good,
Americans love to forgive. Of course,
we're Christians. We love a good apology.
That's the part that I go like, what
do you do? Well, here's the thing.
Some people say,
well,
he already apologized in that letter
and how many times does he have to
apologize?
Well,
as many times as it is necessary to
make the women that he harmed feel
something. Right. And look, it's just,
it's from a fucking PR perspective,
dummy. Yeah. It's just a,
it was a dumb fucking deal.
Do all this shit that Americans like, go
donate money to the women's, blah, blah,
blah. You know, and I'll show,
I'll show that you fucking give
a shit and then come back. Yeah.
That's the way to do it. And I do
have this, I know that Tmz and uh,
NBC, they're all going to take this from
us and hopefully they'll credit. Um,
we actually got in touch with
somebody who was on the street.
I guess that's does it Macdougal street
where the club is right after the show.
Wow.
They found someone who was walking out
right after the show and it just hasn't
made it anywhere else.
But here.
So this is that post that
Luis said at the cellar.
Pretty incredible stuff here.
So you were at the Louis CK show.
What'd you think?
How big his Dick was?
Real?
Did he masturbate each
act dog board drill.
Wow. Was it a lot? Yeah.
Yeah.
Hot white come.
That's really something and it
makes me wish I'd seen him or dread.
Wow. That's incredible.
That's really something. Oh
man, we need a, yeah, Pretty Wild, Huh?
Pretty good stuff there.
Hot and thick. Come,
I didn't know that men
really were invested in the
hotness and the thickness of
it. It makes a difference,
doesn't it? Are you more,
are you happier when it's hotter and
thicker? I've never know. I mean,
the thickness. Some I never
think about temperature. I
mean, sometimes you go like,
wow, this is really, really kind of thin.
And what does that do? You
know, does that mean anything?
It feels like it's you've,
you're draining yourself like thickness
usually I think to people goes like, oh,
I'm backed up. This has been sitting in
others. There's more swimmers in that.
Yeah. You're like, I'm really
producing some stuff. Well, no,
just like I haven't emptied the tank. Oh,
so it's darker cloudier Saudi or brine.
Yeah. And then when it's real thin, you're
like, man, I need to put this thing away.
Something's going on. Um,
do you know where you are? A
big John Landis Fan, right?
Sure. Who's the director of? Oh, right.
No, I don't know. What did he make?
John Landis has an incredibly, he's
like an eighties guy. Yeah. Yeah.
I love eighties movies.
Let's see him. Ivan Reitman.
Yeah.
Fam Course.
I love the woman a Amy Heckerling.
That woman pretty much made every movie
I've ever loved from the eighties and
nineties. Clueless. She did fast times
at Ridgemont, high European vacation.
All good films.
Um,
so here's some John Landis
stuff. Tiny. I know the name,
but I like animal house, the
Blues Brothers, all blues
brothers. Great places.
Yes.
A twilight zone.
The movie he directed thriller.
No spies like us. Love
that movie. Amigos. Yes.
One little movie called coming to America
for my favorite comedy of all time.
Definitely. He made Beverly
Hills cop three. Great.
He May, let's see. Oh No, actually it's
the third one. Great. Probably not.
Um, but whatever. I mean that's a
pretty insane list as it is. Right?
Those are a lot of home runs, dude. Yeah.
Coming to America as a perfect comedy,
I think. Yeah, that's pretty
Ghostbusters pretty much. Anyways,
this is him and I don't know
when this interview took place,
but I thought you might like this.
Check this out.
Like my brother and I went
and stayed with them and we,
we met Bundy for the first time.
Bundy told me,
you know the first line
that Bundy told you that,
but the first line of every
Hungarian recipe steal a chicken.
Yes. That's something my
grandfather would say to.
And then he's got more,
my grandfather was crazy about Hungarians
Darien's who are the really the
Hungarian Polish or the people who
really founded Hollywood. But the, uh,
sell it though. We continue to
think about Hungaria this though.
There's also a Gary.
It is someone who comes into a revolving
door behind you and exits in front of
me.
Hey, sounds like he's got some
pen up. Uh, yeah. What's the deal?
Is Land is a hunger.
I don't know if he's a hunger.
I think he's definitely talking
to some shit, some shit.
Landis problem. You
know what I mean? That's
first line of every Hungarian recipe.
Steal a chicken.
How dare you know? That's kind of
like when you don't like a group.
Can you say it with a smile
and you put it in jokes,
but I don't think he's a fan. How dare
he? How dare he Hungarian shame me. Yeah.
This is racist. I'm finally
experiencing racism. Just is. Yeah.
He's just feels terrible.
And we're going to look,
we're going to break here in a moment,
but I've got to tell you, this is amazing.
You're never believed. Check
his privilege. Check your
privilege. John Landis talk,
talking shit about
toxic shows. Um, Landis.
Guess who's been listening to the show?
Oh,
well I'll let you watch and listen.
Okay.
You're going to die when
you see who it is. Okay.
There's a some outstanding folks
I can tell. They look very smart.
Okay. I miss him there. He's visiting.
Check out. I don't want somebody
laughing at me or saying I don't belong.
Pulled up so you don't try it out.
Try it out.
Right.
Former president Barack Obama.
Barack Hussein Obama. Play it again. I
tried it out. I can't believe it. Yeah.
Yeah, there's some, you
beat me. Try it out. I mean,
clearly that's a direct,
try it out.
I direct reference and he's doing it. He's
doing the show house. It'll try it out.
She couldn't be any,
any more of on man.
Try it out. So there it is. 44 is a fan.
Um, wow. Uh, yeah. Thank
you miss him in a way,
like just his personality. Politics
aside. I just miss having like a calm,
rational person lead. He's got a good
personality, I don't think. Yeah.
Knock his personality for sure. That's
what I'm saying. Like politics aside,
I just liked brack and Michelle. Yeah.
It's part of being a politician as being,
you know, super likable, likable,
nice teeth. I both had good teeth.
Got good teeth. Yeah. Those dogs,
those Portuguese water dogs. Nice. That's
right. What does it bow right? Oh yeah.
That was the, I don't know. I think Bose
dead now. Those dead, I'm not sure. Yeah.
Um, do you want to break now?
You want to Sasha Malia? Ooh,
I want to say something or you want
to take a break? No, no, let's do it.
Let's keep rolling. Okay. Um, this, I also
found this morning and made me so happy.
You know, when you just are filled with
joy at seeing something pulled off. Yeah.
This fucking guy,
he's Asian and he was at a Mcdonald's
and he relies on the walls like of there
like posters. It's just white
people. And he was like,
I feel like we're underrepresented.
So he made his own poster. Oh good.
And he put it up at that Mcdonald's
and they haven't taken it down.
So your hands are underrepresented
too? It's uh, it's pretty amazing.
I just kind of skim through his video,
but like, oh my God. So he ordered,
this is this kid. He, uh,
he's at Mcdonald's, you know,
he notices like this empty wall and he
notices that the posters are just like,
you know, white kids. So
he has a picture made,
he throws logos on and he orders it
from like a whatever. What is it called?
The Kinko's or whatever that makes,
that's Rad.
I have to
look at that. Oh, that's awesome.
It's like, and he threw like the
same graphics that they have on it.
Yeah. Same stupid. And they
throw a Mcdonald's logo at
the bottom here. It's great.
And then, and we made a date with
other friends to go hang it up.
The Big Day was upon us. I loaded
the post stroke, my dad's car,
I met our friends there. I'm there. This,
I wore a jacket covering my uniform and
wait until the coast was clear from any
employees.
He also,
he got, he went to a thrift store. Yeah.
And he got to Mcdonald's like an old meat,
like a Mcdonald's shirt that was there.
And then he made a laminate that said like
regional. Oh, you know, um, I don't know.
Oh, so he's like, I'm, I'm the
corporate bubble by as this new artwork.
Just think place though.
Like he didn't actually introduce himself.
How's The coast is clear? I would take
off my jacket toe Christian, Cassandra,
how to visit you.
That's him
regional.
Teary. Your directory.
That's it. Totally made up.
I love it. It is [inaudible]
it was up. Oh, I need a second.
Okay, so we put the poster up and
I gotta change my shirt. I'm so,
I'm like over the main
Cassandra.
This is Christine.
I'm shaking.
I'm changing right now.
Okay. I got this. It's okay.
Right? That was something, wow,
that's been upset. I really, oh,
it's been a few weeks.
No one noticed works there that
they added this poster and it's,
it'd be like if we took a picture of
ourselves and you put it up there,
no one said anything. He, he tweeted
today. That's how I found out about this.
It's been 51 days.
51 days.
This guy made a poster of himself and
his friend trying to put it up in and
Mcdonald's. Yeah. That's
so good. So great.
I love it. I know. It made me so happy,
so much. Seriously. Watch this today.
I was just,
they'll never take it down.
Remember folks,
all races deserve recognition.
Okay. Lab and I guess I did my part
and that's like,
they're just eating at them underneath.
Do we know where in the world this
is? I don't know. They do this.
You can see this video. This
guy's a youtube channel. It's, um,
his name is j. E. V. H. Oh my
God. Or you can just search.
We became Mcdonald's poster models,
I guess Jeff.
Anyway, I fucking love.
So amazing. I'm loving it.
Ah,
that's so awesome. Yeah,
they're right though. I mean,
Mcdonald's is around the world.
It's not just white people. I mean,
you can go pretty much anywhere in the
world and there's Mcdonald's. There's no,
you can go everywhere. Yeah.
No, they're, it's an, it's a,
that's probably only not in
Antarctica. It's everywhere. I know.
It's pretty amazing. Right.
And do you know that? I mean
they, yeah. Anyway, they can,
they can build one in like
less than a week or something
crazy. I know. Let's see.
How many Mcdonald's,
um,
locations are there?
Let's see.
Mcdonald's restaurants
are in 120 countries and
territories. Uh, they operate,
there's 36,000,
899 right now.
Yeah.
Crazy.
That is nuts. Here is the list.
That's pretty funny. Oh my God. See?
Pretty much everywhere.
South Africa was going to ask love Africa,
Africa that does that. But there is like,
what is this? This is in Africa and Asia.
It's fucking crazy. Oh yeah. South Africa.
Mom's straight. Leah. I've eaten it a few.
They're all over South America it looks
like, except for whatever that is.
America number one. That is,
it's embarrassing. Which one
do you know? I don't know.
This one.
He was at believes.
I don't know. I don't fucking
know, but they're everywhere else.
It's been a while since seventh
grade. Yeah, it would opa.
Yeah. Even those dirty
roof skis. How's he too?
Yeah. It's a lot. Pretty
impressive stuff. Yeah.
I'm really,
I'm really amazed by what those you,
but you would think that Mcdonald's will
be really up on that multicultural tab.
You know, I just think it's funny that
the manager is that Mcdonald's was like,
oh yeah, they finally got that poster
taken care of that wall. Hey, now,
but people are generally very
unobservant now let's see what happened,
because this is the kind of
thing that that tweet went viral.
They're going to figure out
where that is the coupe.
The cool thing is that Mcdonald's
could make it really cool and be like,
hey, you know, we discovered that this
was at this and celebrate it and be like,
guess what?
That poster staying up and we're going
to give you free French fries for a year
or whatever. Or they could be like,
ah, it's not okay to do that. You know,
vandalism. Yeah. I hope they,
I hope they back to PR kind of
manage it in a smart way, you know,
I think makes me happier than
clever vandalism. I know it really,
I swear it just tickles my little
taint. I just love it. You know,
even something as small as in um, in
school when he used to have, I dunno,
they have textbooks anymore and you
could take your eraser and like erase the
eyeball on somebody's picture and then
draw a bigger one and like do shit like
that.
And so like the next kid gets to your
talents and are just erasing big Dicks,
you know,
you erased it and then you draw the Dick.
There's a poster of a real
estate guy at one of these,
it's like near a high school right here.
And the poster hangs there and they cut
his eyes and they cut his mouth out and
he's like,
it looks terrifying.
I feel bad for the GAA cause I know he
paid for it and then he replaced it.
But it was like that for a while and
he was like, thanks a lot dick heads.
It's pretty great. But it's
high school kids. You know,
they're going to do something like that.
Of course.
Why don't we take a break gene and
uh, we'll be back with our guests. Uh,
Brenda's swab. Brenda, I think
that's her name. Isn't that her name?
You may have heard of the finance here.
Charles Schwab.
He had a daughter Brenda, who recently
transitioned to a man and he's here now.
Brendan Charles Schwab mess things up for
me. I'm sure. Did you look like a man?
Thanks Bro. Good job. Good job. Yeah,
I totally would believe
you. A guy. Yeah. Um,
real quick before we get
into some other stuff here,
I just pulled this up from episode
four 61 of your mom's house.
I don't know if you could comment
on this for us at all. He was,
then we started talking about
how Tiger Tiger fucking dumb now.
Oh no being times, but you hear it. You
had to play this for him. Please do it.
Brendan Schaub son's name is
tiger. It is. No, it's not. Yes
it is.
It's a great name.
And in this case it's a
nickname. Retinas. This is real.
People would have allowed us to get
away with not doing. People tag me.
They're like,
yeah,
I'm sorry I forgot your love you.
Here's the thing with that.
This little dude has everything,
man.
He's grown up in silk sheets and Santa
Monica. Yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Pop was rich. So rich
business is booming, so he's,
he has a good life, right?
I need him not to be
the cool kid in school.
I need them to have
something to poke fun at me.
Like your name's tiger going to be like
Scott, former UFC fighter. You know,
he's got weird ears. Yes.
Yeah. Like they're not,
there's not a lot that can go,
there's not a lot brown.
So I figured,
let me push back from the Wa is always,
you know, naming of something is a child.
Obviously. The big thing it's like
was was the wife cool right away?
What's she like?
We had all these names picked out
Max.
Again,
that Mexican Tiger Woods is
an example where you're like,
oh, I figured that assholes
making a comeback because
he was kind of gone and, uh,
I went here.
We had all these names picked out.
This one's going to flinch up first,
but now I want you to sit on it
cause it's different. Cause I,
I don't like regular names like
Jim, Bob just hear me out here.
Tiger. And she was like,
what? And I'm like Whoa, face
that I fucking mate. I know,
right? Most people don't sit on it
for the night and next one she's like,
I'm not mad at. And as soon as she was
like starting to feel it out, boom,
that's it.
Tiger patch shop.
What's an Alliant pax packs
after my uncle who passed away.
Who's a good guy?
He's a real piece of card piece of shit
because I really want this kid to hit it
home.
This is your mom's house.
Do you think we could,
he would have left and
everyone would have been like,
how did you not bring up the tiger bit?
No loyalty you have.
But I also knew that he
wouldn't be like, no, hell no.
I know I had to tell Rogan's
name was talking to on areas.
You never shot a tiger on my,
please don't be mean to me about the
phone call when we call it. Okay.
So it's like a big deal
to reveal the name. Right.
And like sometimes you hold onto it,
you know,
even let's say you know the name a month
before we held onto the second one.
So the first one I'm saying like,
you know,
like you'll say you knew
tiger at six months for sure.
And people will start asking you, do you
know the name? And you might be like, ah,
not yet. Because you don't
necessarily want to tell every,
you want them to judge like a new tattoo.
Totally. That's a really good analysis.
So when people like me like tiger,
that's ridiculous. And then
it burst your bubble. No, it's
cool. Yeah. So, but we, uh,
we held on forever. We kept, we
kept lying about like, like, Nah,
I've just haven't figured it out. And like
family would be like, you have no, no.
I'd be like, nope, I haven't thought of
anything. You to creative souls, nothing,
nothing. And then
finally it was, you know,
we're at eight months on the
first kid and a we call weird.
I remember we were driving and palace
fair days and we pulled over. Oh yeah.
And my parents and they're like,
oh are you going to tell us the name?
And I was like, let's do it. And you were
so excited. I know. I was so excited.
And my mom is Peruvian, you know, so like
heavy accent. Yeah. And I go, she's like,
tell us the name to me.
All, all right. I go,
we're naming him and this is verbatim.
How is when I go, we're naming him Ellis.
And she goes, is he gay? No,
my unborn son. That's
your SWOT. Is he gay?
I'm like, well I don't know yet. We
could be. And then she's like, oh,
I'm like the fuck man. He's
like, Hey Leese I'm like that.
That's your fee. I'm telling
you your grandson's name. No,
she goes [inaudible] like Perry
Ellis. Perry Ellis had aids. Yeah.
Damn mom. No, I don't say I'm
still scarred in the pain.
Yeah, I don't say shit cause
it's my mother in law. I can't,
I can't talk shit to her the same way he
can. So I, yeah. You know what I'm saying?
Like it's been really fun to share
this with you. Well, you know my dad,
you know my dad said, uh, when I first
found out I was pregnant, he goes,
you know what's a good name?
Art Are Sir, which is my dad's name. Yeah.
Cool. Thank you dad. Thank you. Fine.
I got,
he's hitting the worst man.
He said it like he was telling
you about a name he heard. Yeah.
So you know what I mean? It'd
be like you're like, Hey,
do you know what I actually like
a kind of a cool name is cause I,
I don't hear it like all the time. And
you're like, wait, what? Like her name,
you go like, you know, the day I
told him my name and they're like,
that's a cool name. And
you're like, wait a minute,
are you telling me about
your fucking name right now?
And that's exactly how he told him that.
I told him when my girlfriend was pregnant
and when I came home and she had like
the test, I'm like, Oh shit, we got to
call someone and get to tell someone.
And I was like, Oh, I to
call my dad first. My Dad's
like very strict businessman,
like super business where I get all my
work ethic from and I call my dad and I
have it on speaker phone. My girls like
in tears, all excited and I'm like,
watch this. I put, Hey Daddy, what's up?
I go join US pregnant silence.
And he goes,
Damn, uh, why? No,
you don't have to keep it right click,
I'll call you back. And I went, whoa.
I did not think it was gonna go like that.
He said something like,
he said something like, well you know,
you don't have to get married, right.
Or something like it was not good
cause were you guys dating? Yeah,
we were dating, you know,
for like a year or two.
And that was his opposition to
the, yeah. Why would he say that?
He was just like damn,
just being practical.
I'm saying like young rapper
or something like that.
You're an adult, but he
said, man, take it easy.
You have brothers and sisters.
I have an older brother and his,
does he have children? He does
not. He's a psycho. He's selfish.
He loves my son, but he, uh, I dunno.
He's a psycho. He's my tournament.
She's on the road with me. He's like,
oh, really? Yeah, he just really met him.
I'm sure I met him at that fight. That,
that I shared against you on it. Oh yeah.
I told him like, oh, I forgive you. Didn't
know my son's name. He works against
him now. I would be jumping
up and down for him. I know.
I just mistakenly thought Matt
Mitrione went to Lsu. So mom, bro,
sometimes to think about
if I took a fight again,
I'll come out with a comedy store shirt
and have all my Korean friends with me
and walk to the ring with
you. Yeah, I went to be sick.
And what if everybody like Tuh Tuh Tuh
further in the joke just made a goofy
faces as they walked in and like a
bunch of clones, a bunch of clowns.
And I get my password. It's all horrible
at night. I was at a fight when it's,
I want to tell it like a dozen of these
fights, uh, opening for Joe for a while.
Um, so, and I hardly knew anybody,
but there was a guy one time who came
out in a pink Tutu and his gimmick there
was like a joke and he played
lineman, not Ed Herman. Uh,
Dave Herman did that maybe,
and he came out to weird song,
he came back to a weird song and he was
wearing a tutu and everybody was like,
well, he better fucking win because
if you lose on this, it's like,
why are you playing games? It's even
worse. And I think he did lose titty.
Did you ever see the guys who came out?
It was a Australian or New Zealand cat
and they must have studied all night and
they came out the exact men
in black outfits and did
the dance here come the man
in black. Yeah. Loser with I think key
one you got to win if you do something.
You know what I mean?
If you're,
if you're not focused on your fight
cause you're doing dance routines,
then you're a meme for the
next 10 years and if you're,
if you're a whole thing is like
I'm going to wear a pink Tutu.
You better when you got to win or
you're just crazy. Totally crazy.
I just had a thought back related to like
telling your parents really important
stuff in your life.
Doesn't that make it like be really
cognizant now when your children tell you
something like just killing sided
just always pretend hurts my feelings.
I've told her a bunch of times about
one of my aunts will be like, um,
you know,
she'll come to a show and when like
other relatives obviously are going to be
like you were great, you know the
way a relative does, she'll be like,
I thought everyone was great though.
She'll make the point,
they don't get how bad that
hurts me as an athlete or comic.
You're sensitive man. Of course.
I remember you saying that.
That just when I played at University of
Colorado had to sit out a year so I red
shirted so I went playing the
games, not suit up. I remember,
I won't say what family member it is cause
we get pissed and so all the families
there were all the players go and
I went and they're like, oh my God,
you played so great. That
was fantastic. I was all
fuck you man. I get
hurt. My feelings so bad.
Or I remember my first time my mom saw
me do stand up was at the laugh factory
at the laugh factory and
sports. It's horrible. Oh my
God. I come out and I go to,
you get it. I go, do you guys
have fun? Goes my mom was, it was,
it was an interesting, you know, and she's
changed it real fast. You went, yeah,
I saw Kevin Nealon though.
No,
the right answer is you are fantastic.
I'm so proud of you for trying
something. Yeah. You know,
my mom's side's me. She saw
me in the belly room and I
did. Well, I didn't do like,
I didn't eat shit. I didn't kill. I did
okay. And she's like, Van, you know,
it's not like what you
are saying is funny.
I like how you say it. And
I was like, thank you. Thank
you. Was that even at that,
it also gave me like, um, even now,
like God, my dad would be like,
I,
uh,
I pay attention to the audience and the
moments that they laugh and where they
don't like that one thing,
they didn't laugh. Oh my God,
he does. Or if I give, like if I do like
pho anger, you know, it's not like, yeah,
fuck this shit. He's like, I
don't know if I would do that.
Thank you for the notes. I'm glad to
hear. Thank you Chris Rock for the notes.
We got to get him doing movie reviews
on this show. That'd be hilarious. Um,
oh wait, wasn't it? Oh, you know what I
love when he tells you to do, he's like,
you know what you should do buddy is
regional. He'll go reference it. Yeah.
I'm like, no one's ever thought of
this. He's like, that's brilliant. Pops.
He's like,
cause you remember that time you're in
Minnesota and you said how cold it was.
Yeah.
My thought, first of all, why dad was in
Monterey at the car show with my brother,
this is last week, mind you
and sewn goes. Someone goes,
AH, they're talking about, uh,
kids. And my dad goes, oh yeah, my,
my son lives in California. And they
guy goes, oh, what's he do out there?
And my dad goes, uh, he
gets on stage and then, um,
he's like an Internet personality,
but then he'll get on stage and like tell
stories in my brother, you know, he's,
my tour manager goes, no, he'd just stand
up comedy Demo Day goes, no, no, no, no.
He didn't do that. He gets on stage and
like tell stories you didn't do comedy.
And my brother's was like,
that's exactly what he does.
Why would he make that distinction?
I just, he just doesn't. Or by Dad,
this is like, oh my God. It's
like a year ago goes, you know,
I think you should do some, I mean, you
should do some bits on Trump. I want it,
dude. I can't believe I didn't stand out.
That's exactly what I should do that,
wait, did he, when
you grow up,
when you were growing up,
did he likes to end up like you remember
him watching specials? No, not really. No.
My mom did. My mom did comedy buck.
Who was she into? Do you remember?
We'd watch Saturday night live every
weekend. She loved it all. Yeah. Oh,
that's cool. Your dad like none of that
was like for sure. Pick a football.
So fucking stupid street football,
wreck your brain, pick up,
shut the fuck. Think sign me up
for tech. Football on us for that.
Now you're, you're obviously
in a committed relationship.
Now when you were a single guy,
did you request or even demand that
a woman eat your scrum regularly or no,
you're from behind.
Y'All got that Nigga fuck that up
John or whatever the fuck his name is.
Most of the Niggas out here
talking about him. Hey,
one of these niggas asks you that
made a status like you also perfect.
Oh God ain't no wrong.
We get a Nigga gave his ass.
Ain't my motherfucking females and I
saying that cause I eat Niggas as I'm
saying that because it is what it is.
So here's what it is. It's ass
eaten. Not Ass eight. Right?
Well I mean automatically you bet
your ass a lot of tomato, whatever.
I mean were you big into this? Not really
my thing, I've had girls go for it.
Go for it. I've had girls take
my linkedin, bend it back,
change your died. I tried.
Wow. I put up with it for
a little bit and I'm like,
this is why I put it up so I don't wanna
I don't wanna learn a little more sway.
That might be my favorite gesture of all.
I've put up with it for a little bit.
Well my legs, my thighs are big song
about fucking leg drop. A bit like down.
I don't need that big dude.
I know I pinned my legs like that.
Pretty big girls. You'd be surprised
the wiring, the wiring strong one.
Really? Yeah. So, uh, you tolerated
it. I tolerate weren't into it.
Uh, not my thing. She
says kind of disgusting.
You know you said some
and words like it here,
get you fingers and Annee de she's as
crazy question about my Nigga book a girl
ina do as did you suck his dick?
You licking his boss, right? Bitch,
she makes you a pulmonologist
eating niggas acid. So
don't be like punch a bitch.
No, cause I asked that I'd be like she
can't, what's up? Can I eat your laugh?
Cause I like him. He goes, Hey Mitch,
all on his case or whatever light.
He ain't the only Nigga I like
and his motherfucking ass. Aight.
I bet it's alarming number that do like
it. Oh yeah. I think I've told this
before, but this is when I, when I
worked in DC, after I graduated college,
I had a job for a few months and um,
uh,
I remember Tracy was a black dude I
worked with at America's most wanted in DC
on Wisconsin Avenue and one day I give
Tracy a ride and he sat in the passenger
seat. He was like, you
know, like, like what's up?
He's like broke up with my girl man. I
was like, I was like, Oh shit. Really?
I was like, how long were you together?
He's like, three years. I want to go.
Damn man. Like what happens?
Like showing my ass no more.
I was like, Shit. I was like, this is the
reason that you broke up. And he was like,
yeah, Dan is like, you mean
like the foundation of your
relationship piece of it.
And he was like,
she won't do it no more.
I mean cold if that's your thing though
that if you would like to your main,
if that's like what you guys
are built on its ass and eating.
She doesn't do it when aren't you gay?
If their main thing is but stuff.
No because it's just the ass
heating and we would like,
cause she put fingers in there
like she said if he was like Dicks,
there's always discipline indexes gave
tongues are not are unquestionably gay.
I had a here that's like yeah have you,
if he was left this other dude
won't fuck my ass no more.
So I broke up with my girl.
I'll be like yeah I think you're gay bro.
You know what's interesting
about ass eating though?
It's like it's having the audacity to
enjoy it because I think I think why we're
so opposed to it cause I'm sure having
your but like just pleasurable right?
It's,
I mean it's nice but it's really being
that person was bold enough to be like
you fucking lick my ass.
I don't care how dirty that should cause
cause I'm so self conscious, I'm like,
Ooh, there's probably Brown there.
Even though I'm pretty clean.
It's having the balls to be like,
it's fucking Likud.
It's also just fucking, you're the
person doing it. It's like I'm dangerous.
I'm nasty,
nasty shit.
It's like freak level declaring it's
waving the flag and then it's like looking
at you afterwards.
Like you know what kind of person.
But it's also uncomfortable
if they just do it like that.
Nice young lady would ask you
like, I've had it before. We girls,
they have their fingers done it as as
long fake ones and they'll put them
fingers in the rump pole and
you're Dukie shoot. Yeah.
It just depends. No questions
asked that. Guess what?
That's not her first time doing that.
That's what I'm saying. It's Kinda rude.
Yeah, it's a little
rude. It's rude. I know.
One of my friends told me about how he
met online lady who came over and it was
like, okay, you're coming over. He
didn't even, so she's new to him.
He wasn't even prepped, like wash,
showered, and she changed his died.
I went down there on wash be whole.
I used to know a girl that would
only like to have sex, anal,
like chewed. Only want that.
Really? Wow. Wow. But She Persian,
oh, white girl. White girl.
I believed in the Lord or no doubt it.
Yeah.
I said not that and just surprise Ya.
Um,
so our 10 year anniversary is later
this year and we got this email. Uh,
someone said I was delighted to hear
Christina's request for ideas on how to
celebrate your 10 year anniversary
and here are my thoughts.
I can't get all of your friends and
family together for a celebration after
dinner.
Gather them around to show a video of
Youtube scat sex and through a hammer.
Yeah.
That's pooping through the Hummus.
Get on a Ferris wheel
with some family members,
smoke meth and molest each other until
there is a four stroke. Come. Yup. Wow.
Then get a funnel cake.
Wow.
Have some hot black guys with cows
over for a month of rape play.
They can beat you while the cows piss on.
You.
Offer them to stay with you for
awhile and exchange for being there.
Hot White come dumpsters. I hope this
helps. High and tight Jim. Wow Jim. Wow.
Really neat offer. I love
the hope. This helps.
I hope this helps suggest like
corporate. Um, I don't know.
Do you feel like any of
those tickle your feather?
I'll marinate on it a little bit.
We're going to be married for 10 years.
And how long did you guys
date before that? For
long time. So we can get her for a
minute. Yeah. Yeah. He will eat a gene.
I know we have two kids now.
Isn't that crazy?
To me that's the part that's even crazier.
It's weird when you have to get used
to the idea of a child like you.
Like we forget about him. So he's only
six weeks, seven weeks old this week.
Do you feel, I feel like when I had a
kid, life got way more serious for me.
Like so scared of everything.
Think about death daily.
I think about to me dying
daily and thinking about
tragedy happening to both my
children.
Like,
what if they get that weird meningitis
and ended up in the hospital and need a
spinal tap? I had one of those, uh,
those, it's like two wheels in the front,
one wheel on the back,
those little a thing called slingshots.
They sent one to try out
and like have fun with.
When I was younger I
would fucking wheelies,
take a thing of my buddies
hanging off naked or whatever.
But then I got on that thing,
I was going down PCH and also
having fun with it and I was like,
this isn't a bad thing, just don't
have a helmet on. And then I Florida,
I put in a third gear and
it swiped around like,
and I'm facing incoming traffic on PCH.
And literally I was like, I can't do this.
I can't die man. I can't die. You got a
kid. So I literally called him the kid,
come get this thing.
I think about it too.
I know even one of my friends were telling
me about road ratio, the, he's like,
you still have it. And I go, yeah,
I felt habit with this
thing happens now sometimes.
And I think it's from being a
parent where you'll be like,
you know when you have crazy thoughts,
you're like,
I'm just going to for sure t
bone, that car, I'm going to go,
I'm like punched in the fucking window.
Drag that.
Like you start having crazy thoughts
and then you're like, look, I'm a dad.
I can't be like Dan. And then you just
like totally calm down. You're like,
just everybody just go
to these crazy thoughts.
Sorry my thought like Bs.
It is crazy.
I've never felt older because
now I'm like super into my lawn.
That's a real dad shit.
Some Dad Shit Bro.
My lawn watering and my focuses and I'm
just my gate. It's like that's my shit.
That's my shit.
I got real excited about it all too.
I love it, man. Yeah.
I get excited about mail.
Anything home related? Yeah.
I just want to be home. Yeah,
it's of course it's great.
I love being home.
I mean it's obviously our
jobs are all traveling,
but I really look forward to going
home. It's hard. It's hard for me.
It's hard to travel. People are way
better at me. I suck at like vacation,
stuff like that. I don't like hotels
cause when you're on the road,
how many hotels have you
stayed in a hotel? I'm like,
to me like I can't shut down here. Like
I can't relax here in the hotel. I just,
you a rental house? AIRBNB ahead.
Well that's a good idea though.
That's a great idea.
That was really great.
When I'm Burt and Ari and I did it for
that national championship game last year.
Oh that's airbnb. The house. It was,
dude, I was talking about on my show.
Your, I think you watch a
little college football, right?
Yeah, he watches a casual,
I dunno, like in the comedy scene, like
my friends, I don't, I don't know anyone.
And sports count
doesn't,
Rogan doesn't Dalea does.
I was super stoked that college football's
back to frank about it came the night.
Did you let your kids play football?
And I don't know if I don't want
them to on it. I mean the injuries,
no way. No Way. And our sounds
are cannon balls do like,
here's the difference. There's some good
safe sports, soccer, tennis, swimming,
running. I played sports. I played
all through elementary, middle high.
You there is really,
there's just as much danger or playing
soccer as pee wee football because
there's no high, like the hits are not
lying to her fast enough. You're not dude.
They're not.
I still feel like the exception to with
the CT when you see guys come out with
Ct. Yeah. I'm like, yeah, but where's
all the guys who don't have it?
We don't hear from them. The
majority don't have it. Dude,
a kid playing sixth grade football.
He is not the,
it's not like Bo Jackson's out there,
you know Lawrence Taylor's
not fucking blind sight.
What about that big kid on the other team?
There's always one.
There's a Brendan Shab,
you know who's like the fucking enormous
sixth graders once a year. Once a year.
No idea or Jane plan around. Yeah,
and then I take my kiss. I'm like,
kid til you hit that kid in the knee.
You got to take her home and his name.
He was like, what? My head
down crown or he might,
you might be singing a different tune
though when you see him in high school and
he's this baller than Tom comes. They're
like, damn, we got an offer from Stanford.
They were like, why go pick up
that football? Yeah. I Dunno.
I don't want my boys to be weenies though.
I definitely want them to be killer.
Fine Line. Well killers is aggressive.
It's a fine line. Oh, killers. She's,
what'd you get a kid into
Jujitsu is fine for confidence.
Kickboxing. No, no, no. Well I wouldn't
let him spar. Right, but you'd love train.
Well, I'm trained boxing like I
do now and then I hit mits up.
I never get hit in the head.
I'd love football. The,
the juice is worth the squeeze.
You can take him places they
probably wouldn't be able to get,
they're going to meet a
lot of good people network.
Then getting to school is a great team.
Great team. Camaraderie is awesome. Yeah.
Um, wouldn't let him fight.
Definitely when I'm flooded.
No. Fighting's bad. Right?
Terrible. You don't wanna you don't
have to take head shots all the time.
But that's the thing is like
you can play football for
all of elementary, middle, high school,
and maybe have a couple of your bell
rung a few times. You know Jesus if got,
if you've taken it to like one of
these top tier programs in high school,
like where they fucking recruit
and we write the streets.
Taft then no punk. Yeah.
And there's AR,
there's a,
Oh there's IMG academy and you know
these Hoover highs, these programs.
Have you seen one of those games? Yeah.
It's nuts. Yeah, I've been to one.
I was like, what tough. He was, might've
been a little beat us in college.
I did wines. Huge. Crazy.
But then when you start getting these
big time programs like were where he
played.
Yeah,
you could come out like with a
slur and you're speeding like load,
you know.
But I'm saying that's the likelihood
that a kid will be playing that it's like
swimming swimming's need this
women's nice. That's safe.
Tennis if was a better swimmer,
I wouldn't mind that.
That'd be great to year round though.
You gotta go all the way.
You think about this guy, this guy is
going to tell us what he wants to play.
We're always mocking the way people look
and the choices they make up. This guy,
David ferry is a professional, former
professional golfer on the European tour.
He works at a television personality
and he's rocking this beard right now.
What do you think of that? Oh Wow.
I mean look at the, cause his,
the call line is out here.
He did it across the middle of the chewed.
I look at the gun. I think he fucks.
You think he's big Dick Energy.
Key fucks Sake Dick Energy. Okay.
Just sticky energy. Do you think he
deliberately got the shading different?
Like that's an idea for 100%
there's a bad guy from the book.
This is a villain cut. Right?
The billing. But now it's,
as Brendan said that I just pictured
this guy getting off an elevator and
walking into the bar of the hotel and
he's like, just so everyone knows here,
I fucked pretty good. Yes.
That's what I, that's what I,
and he orders his drink from afar.
You know, some people are like,
I didn't come here. I want
to order my help. Yeah. He's
just like, no, we're just,
we're the table.
Oh yeah.
And jumped in his Maserati and fuck
[inaudible] thing gets his ass licked.
Demands on a second.
Yeah.
Do you think like if you're a lady
and you meet him and he's like,
come into my room,
you're like okay.
And then you go to the shower to freshen
up his bathroom and you like put your
makeup on and she would come back in the
bedroom and he's on all fours and he's
like,
that's where it starts.
He pushes your head into it points
back to the forest is yours.
Like you know what to do. See I think
he lays down and just scratch this.
Let's do you think he pulls
it back? A baby? He grabbed
it on ankle. On, yeah. Oh,
one is bold.
That's that big Dick Energy.
But you don't want to have a forest
like a towel. That's not sexy.
It's not sexy balls hanging down the
back. It's a funnier look. It is.
The Big Duke Energy Moves. Lay on your
back and just spread your legs. Yeah,
it's a girl. The girl's like, oh,
like I guess it a cool Maserati.
He's got those big veneers too though.
Hey does he went full white?
Cause he fucks all day over here too.
That's all he cares about.
I'm a Maserati and veneers.
Nothing worse. Eight.
I'm thinking about getting
veneers. He, yeah, my friend too.
They look good. I the best guy. He
makes magic glass. I'll give me,
I didn't even have braces. Check this out.
Okay. I think you had Braille. Listen,
this guy comes in not
pad, Bro. Let me see.
The bottoms are not bad. They're not
great. I mean I've seen wider. Yeah.
All right, thanks. Hey,
that's come from a guy with 50
shades of brown teeth though.
Hold on now let your mind bro. No,
those are good and you've got it.
Yeah. Yeah. What's up?
What's up bro? Hold on.
Now
you were saying you were thinking
about getting your veneers.
What? Which ones would
you veneer though? Yeah,
your teeth are fine. I just feel like
if I had been there it'd be sick. No,
I looked too much like a giant Mario
Lopez. You think? Oh my God. Yeah.
I never thought of AC slash Slater
vibe going on. I do see that.
Do you think he's got that BD? The big
they Kennedy? I don't get it from him.
No to you later. I did. When
we turn this chair backwards,
big Duke Energy. I was on a
plane, went by him and he did,
he did like the terminal and the gate
and the boarding all with sunglasses,
you know, and like I was like,
okay, alright. Alright Bro.
And he did the inside
like the window seat. So,
and he had somebody like a handler and the
ILC. Ah, that's not big. Very different.
No,
it's not necessarily big energy.
Very different though than like his
onscreen persona where he's like, hey,
guess what's in theaters this week? You
know, I did a show with them. He was like,
hey, how you doing Brandon?
Good to see. I'm like, Bro,
who are you talking to them?
Why do your full makeup? Huh? What are
you talking like that? Good to see you.
What do you think? I'm like dude,
you got to stop. Yeah, Hollywood.
Wait too long man. He's got one
of those gigs. It's so visible.
Like it's one of those Hollywood access
is in hotel rooms when you turn on the
TV everywhere.
And it's also um,
you know we take them serious though. No,
I don't think so. He probably knows too,
like this is a good gig in the,
in the grand scheme of things,
this is a gig he's probably
had for fucking 10 years
and heavy and like as long
as you look presentable and
he stays in great shape,
you can just keep being like, here's a,
another new exciting Brian and Schwab
you and stand up again here in Dallas.
Torn box.
And just to keep his man card, I could
take a picture with Oscar de la Hoya.
He'll be at all the fights. That's it. So
he has a podcast that's all boxing too.
So it was it Mario Lopez. He
does. So he really knows his shit.
Then he must think he like
hangs around the fudge.
And so you watch a lot of boxing
or no? Um, I do. Yeah, I do.
You're gonna Watch that fury. Uh,
I'm working it. You're working it.
I'll be working with what
you're calling it. A,
I'll have something to do with that
fight. Yeah. I thought you, it's you.
I didn't know you work outside of
outside of MMA. Yeah. Yeah. Work.
Showtime. But for boxing. Yeah. Dude, I
didn't know that. That's awesome. Yeah.
Thank you. What a, so you can't
like obviously give a prediction,
but I think it's gonna be a good
fight. Great fight. Phenomenal fight.
It's probably going to be,
I don't know if they've announced it
was in Vegas around November 11th.
It's coming up. It's coming up. I would go
to that. That sounds great. Fight. Great.
Fight. Water's a great, yeah, I
love him. He's really like his, um,
I mean, you know, I guess the knock
people have had is that they're like,
you haven't fought top to your talent,
but he is devastating. Great Dude.
And then Tyson fury has a personality.
It's going to be a good fight.
I look forward to the um,
the, you know, the buildup,
the press conferences,
talking, shooting the shit.
Talking [inaudible] what do you guys
watch? Like when you guys are chilling,
you got Netflix and chill. What
do you guys watch? I got you beat.
I worked for Bravo lay.
It just started his job all the time.
Huge Jeff Lewis fans. We're so
excited for fun. You say no more fam.
So what about real housewives
or we're not real housewives.
Married in Madison.
Below Jack below deck.
Mj, Holla at your boy. Seven
seasons. Brendan. June.
All seven seasons. I love that show. Yes.
Believe how much fucking Farsi we've
listened to them in this house.
You guys will love it then
cause a, I leave tomorrow.
It's my first date shooting.
It's like what are you shooting
for? Bravo. So it's a, it's
a talk show that doing,
it's me.
Jerry O'connell.
I know it's produced by Andy Cohen and
like how could they have sandy happy
Jamaican. How many jobs do
you have man? I Dunno man.
I mean I need to pick a lane who's got
multiple podcasts. He's doing stand up.
He's got a showtime MMA
slash boxing jocks. Awesome.
Nice. I mean, really? Yeah. I'm exhausted.
So what's your, what is your Bravo's fun?
That's fun. That's fun. Fun. The most
fun. What's the most fun stand up by far.
If someone held a gun to my head and was
like, hey, you can only do, or whatever,
if you could only do one thing, it'd
be stand up. And what's your best?
What's the best job for you? Look what's
the most, how you be getting lucrative.
The most podcasting standups right
there, right there. That's great.
Along the wrong, the road business.
A boom booming, but he's doing well.
He's doing well. Daddy Daddy
bought a purple Porsche. I know.
It's really shit gold rims on
it. So the thing is though, um,
I uh, between podcasts and stand
up, but if I want to go on the road,
more standard would beat it. But
I mean, yeah. Yeah. That's great.
We please talk about this bravo hookup.
Are you friends with the shires?
I mean,
I'm going to be,
I have you been working with Andy and
he's the producer on this and I fly out
literally tomorrow, 6:00 AM to do in
New York, New York, but we filmed in la,
so we're shooting the first
four in New York and then, uh,
then it's going to be you and
like cohosting yeah. So it's,
it's kind of like the think of like
the view, but for due to watch bravo,
me as a guest, I'm going to fuck you
on. I brought him, definitely male. No,
I would love to do it. Do you know Jerry
O'connell at all? I know who he is.
A great, is it just you two? No, it's
two other guys. Who were the other guys?
I can't say the other game.
The press release comes out
tomorrow and let me tell you,
this won't be out until like
midnight Tuesday night. Yeah,
I should probably wait just suddenly
you're in trouble. I can cut it off here.
Okay. Okay. Yeah, they're
weird about this, but it's
Michael Davies who did like,
who wants to be a millionaire, uh, below
the belt. All these huge shows. And then,
um, Andy Cohen, uh,
Jerry O'connell myself.
I Love Bravo stuff, man.
We watch all that stuff.
You really are doing like a
crazy amount of stuff. Yeah,
I know. Yeah. I mean it's good. It's like
this is a time to do it, man. Yeah. Yeah.
I could do this when you're 50. No, hell
no. I couldn't. No, I couldn't. Yeah,
I feel like eventually
I had to pick a lane.
Have you ever seen this video of this guy?
You're killing it.
[inaudible]
you seen this?
Because she'll come over and we'll
buy your badge and mall. Yuck. Yeah,
he'll be come on with us. So that will
be fine. Right? Yeah. Those minds.
Jimmy Olsen, I keep allowed to fit down
the others. I keep what to sound. Hey.
Yeah.
Now that one's fun. Oh, you like no one's,
you know, I like it. Tell me. Right.
Well I can understand what they're saying.
Okay.
And like was Portuguese is
Portuguese. He got 200 volts. He
no way. Oh Shit. Oh God. Yeah.
See Cause I thought that small of a shark
won't kill him. Yeah. So I feel like,
oh wow. I mean he fell down and not doing
well. Have you, have you seen Mr. Herring
[inaudible] get a voice box?
I'll be right back. Oh my God.
See it's a funny screen and it's like
old timey. That was an old asked.
How's that different than the
Taiwanese guy? I don't know. Oh,
another one they showed. Yeah, there
is a man who had his legs crushed.
Did Not Miss Portside when
he's gentlemen. Uh, you, no,
here's what I didn't like them because
he was screaming in agony and pain and
then people kind of weren't
helping him and it was prolonged.
Like that was just a fast, here
it is. This is the fuel, right?
No. See, watch.
Oh my God.
You sociopath.
It just goes on and on like it's too long.
It's too depressing
us guys.
Yeah.
And it goes on and it's too
long. I feel like, oh my God,
please helping it.
I feel like he's okay though.
He is. Yeah, he's fine.
He doesn't give a shit. No,
he never told Asians. Yeah.
By the way.
We had an update a week ago or two weeks
ago that I'm from a Taiwanese breast
where this happened that said that, um,
he just had bruises. He wasn't even there.
How does he know that? We read it on the
shift. I know, but now in retrospect,
because it was in the news, they're like,
he was like, ah, and like looked in wade,
but he's kind of cool and apparently he
was just saying because we were always
like, what does he say? We don't know.
He's saying he was saying stuck
could the equivalent of stuck stock.
You don't say that if you die. Yeah, I
know that they snap. No, if you're dying,
you just go,
you know why I liked the
electrocution wine? Oh, tell me.
Because that one's just like a cartoon
beat. Like it's a fat. It's, it's quick.
You don't see his face. It's a
good quick punchline. That one,
I get to know that dude. You
know what I'm saying? Oh my God,
this guy hit the ground.
Yeah, I don't like this. Yeah.
Better do something.
I would never do this ever. Pros, cons.
I've done it.
That one is way was pretty happy.
It's Hilarious,
but that's the way it sounds
like he blew out his knees.
It's that super funny to my husband.
That's pretty funny. I don't know why.
It's funny. See, I don't know why. If I
as I know he's okay. It's funny. Yeah.
The thing is you can't
control it going to get hurt.
There's no way to be
tough about it. Yeah, no.
It was the most horrific injury you've
had. I've been fortunate, man. I haven't,
you know, I mean her mom freak
when she saw you doing this stuff.
Uh, yeah. My Dad like wouldn't
sleep at night and stuff.
I can't imagine my son fighting. I
can't imagine. I know I didn't ever had,
he goes too crazy. He was crazy.
You know that one time when I was,
when I was in high school playing ball,
it was like one of those weeks
where my dad was out of town. So my,
my mom doesn't know
anything about football.
Like she would watch entire
games and be like, oh,
I was watching the other guy like
that. You know? It doesn't know,
but a game like one of the only games
she went to alone just to be supportive.
You balled out? No, I went to an
ambulance, took me to the hospital. Damn.
What happened on a punt coverage,
like as the whistle blew and like, you
know you're running full speed. Yeah.
And then you're, you're slowing
down, right? Like you're
slowing your sprint down.
One of the,
a guy took out my legs and I went up
into the air and landed on my tailbone.
Damn.
Broke the tailbone.
I didn't break it but they didn't know
what was wrong cause I was like, oh,
when you land on it, yeah. You never know.
Paralyzed and they realize he's
going to hospital. Did you,
did you have aspirations of
playing college or Pro Green guys?
I didn't know how like much I didn't know.
You know what I mean? Ignorance is
bliss. It is. I was like, oh man.
Like I'll probably play it like
Auburn or something. I really did.
I had no idea. I'll probably, it's
probably come down Florida state.
I'll improvement. Yeah. I mean I
really thought that. I'm not kidding.
That's how everyone is
though, I guess. I mean,
I've told this story before the
the time that I didn't like,
because the thing is when you're in
high school it's such a different game
because of the like you can make plays
all the time be like, I mean I'm good.
Right? Yeah. Yeah. And so when I, when I,
I thought I'm a decent player. I mean
I knew it was above average. I did,
but I didn't know the difference
between an above average and elite.
And even though there was guys on my
team that were elite and I was just like,
you know,
you kind of are in denial about it.
It's like being in denial but
anything you're like, well
I beat him in this, this,
this. It's like you see the say I see
the same denial tree doing standup.
Like sometimes you're like,
I don't know why this person
is still doing this after
like 50 yeah, yeah. Within,
they still do it.
But I do like, I feel like a,
I don't mean to interrupt you.
I feel like in stand up it's very
black and white and you're like, well,
you're not getting laughs though man.
You're not selling tickets on the road.
The other thing too,
I always measured this in stand up where
it was like year one and then I was
like, is your, when I got
to year two I was like,
am I better at stand up and I'm
working more, I'm getting more work.
And that's how I would measure it.
I'd be like, man, you know, I was,
I was emceeing and now featuring.
So like I'm definitely making progress
and all I ever wanted to see was progress
and, and then you know, you,
you can start to measure the
quality of what you're doing.
And there's definitely a lot of
people that are delusional in,
in all entertainment, singing,
acting, you know, but a standup,
you can kind of see it,
you're like, you're making
zero progress after 10 years.
And sometimes people
just, you know, they did
standup,
you can chill a lot longer,
but you cannot do to took Kevin
Hart 15 years. Yeah, yeah. I guess.
Yeah. But in football it's like,
no, no schools, no school on.
She played for the team. Now I'm very
black and white. I, you know, I had like,
I got like the d two and
d three recruit letter
and I had a couple of
clicks. Yeah, yeah, sure.
These are people that don't
know that I probably have.
I'm still in it for a million years.
I never knew that they send you,
they send you form letters
though. So they're like, are,
we were impressed with how strong you
are on the grid iron and in the classroom
and like, my grades are terrible. It's
like a form letter, but it's, yeah,
it's kind of thrilling. You Open it, you
know, and you're like, it's kind of cool.
So I would get some of these, but I was
like, I want to go to holy cross, man.
I'm going to go to
fucking, you know, Florida.
My hold out to Mitch and when exactly.
And when I went on,
I went on a trip with a guy in my team
who was a legit baller and we went on the
field to watch Syracuse
play Miami at Miami.
And when those guys came out of the
tunnel and they were standing next to me
pregame, I was like, there was a
no, I don't look like these guys.
Like I would die on the scout team here.
I would die.
I mean it hit me that,
that it was my level of delusion
went away in an instant.
I was a junior in high school,
so it was a good thing to recognize.
It shows your smarts though. You're
intelligent level. Cause a lot of guys,
there's a lot of guys who even, they
see that and they go I can still do it.
Then somehow they walked on where they're
just scout team guys and you're like,
dude,
you're never going to play.
And they're going to put you through
the wringer. Like dude, Rudy did it.
And like when he had one
fucking play five years,
they Linde play one play when he's off
sides. You know what I'm saying? Like this
doesn't, hmm. I would have been massacred.
I mean I probably, if I was one of those,
because there's these psycho guys that
love the game so much that they'll like,
I'll suffer no matter what.
Cause I love this game and I'm
definitely not that person.
But there's guys like done stand up too.
That's true.
That's got a bomb 5,000 tons so we can
call yourself a comedian or you just suck
it, calm it better. I'm
like, no, that's not true.
I know some of the great say that I don't
agree with it. I think if you bombing,
if you're bombing that much
out of a thousand times,
you don't have any bits of anyone.
Last night and we all,
we all bomb if you bomb all the time.
Me and Bert were talking, I think it was
on his podcast. He goes, yeah. He goes,
yeah,
me and Tom realize that you're really
going to do this comedy thing cause we at
the store in the back and you
were bombing and I was like, what?
And he goes and then we came back and
you're like, oh God. That was like, yeah,
shit happens man. We did. We said that
it's a bird said he's just an exaggerated,
I'm sure it was a rough night though.
They're this rough nights, man.
There are rough nights. Of course you
should have rough nights. Hell yeah.
If you're like,
I've had great shows,
that means you've done stamp like eight
times all going shows. Shows. Yeah.
But you also shouldn't be bombing every
single on the true, that's for sure do.
Yeah, that's true, man. No,
it is crap. I mean, you played
at that elite level. I mean,
I definitely would have died. I would
didn't, they would've have, you know the,
I could have been that kid who's like,
I could be a scout team full
back or something. Some guy,
just a battery last me.
Yeah. They're just like, oh,
we gotta get you neck surgery this off.
Thanks for your, and then I'm just like,
I just love the team so much. And like
they, they just put it for the team.
I'm like, ah, I'm not gonna
be able to look left or right
for the rest of my life.
This is the benefit.
I have with my kids is a,
I've been at the high
level in multiple sports.
I'm like homeboy and prying freshman
in high school. I'm like, dude,
we got to pick a different lane.
This,
you're not getting it right away if
the aptitude is there. Yeah, pretty.
Pretty close. Yeah. Yeah. You
can write. I remember a guy,
a coach come in and he was like,
you, uh, he was like, you guys,
just all you all should
worry about is your speed.
So just working on your speed and like,
what if you already fast? He was like,
yeah, you too man. Got
that check. What else?
What else man? What else? From the
short while? What else you got Doug?
You try to put on weight. He was
like, yeah, it's going pretty well.
So anything else? I was like, so
I got it. I'm fast. I'm meeting.
Yeah. No, those people are different, man.
They're totally different. Yeah. Yeah.
Sick of innate.
What,
what a good segue from sports or what
other shows you guys watch though? Oh,
Bravo. What about Netflix? Yeah, we'd
definitely, where he fucks with El Chapo.
He does. He loves it. Oh you speak
Spanish. Of course. I'm almost done.
I'm almost done. I'm in season three
episode 11 or 12 come on 12 it's really
good. The whole, the series is great.
Brilliant. And I was talking about,
I was talking,
I was putting out the doubt when,
when I was pressing play originally I
was like look, not to talk about of Shit,
but a lot of these Latin
American productions are
whack. Like when you watch,
you know a show that airs on Telemundo
or some shit like man this is,
this is not the same.
That show the writing, the
directing, the cinematography,
everything is tremendous on it.
Do you ever go back and you can,
they'll show some of it but you can go
back and watch like major scenes and El
Chapo,
his life where he got arrested or when
he escaped from prison and you watch when
they recreate it and
it is fucking spot out.
Small details to everything. I wonder
how much, I mean you can tell it,
you know what parts are 100% true.
I wonder like if,
how much of that of like other characters
and exaggeration or completely made
like the [inaudible] character, it's
like, which one's the, you know,
the secretary of state,
the gay guy. I mean he's,
he was gay,
you know,
who knows what he's doing that side
piece and if you'd like to get that,
but is that based on a real guy? That's a
real guy. That definitely is 100%. Okay.
100%. Yeah. My girls Mexican as fuck. And
I asked her, I'm like, Calvert legitimate.
She's like pretty legit.
And she'll bring me like the actual,
I never looked it up. Yeah.
We, I get balls deep. Yeah.
I love that guy. That plays, they'll
Chapo. He's excellent. Here's my thing,
what's the,
what is this humble we going to do?
He's like the girl on those
Frickin, you know, on those, uh,
the insurance ads. Oh, right.
Well, I don't know though,
because like why don't see,
he's going to be cap type,
type it up a chameleon because when he,
when he's El Chapo, um, you know,
like breaking in to the
business and then when he's, uh,
when they fast forward to the New York
with his head shakes the same at all of
us. I think it looks all Chapo.
That's it. I think he's screwed. Rowe.
I think he's pretty good.
No about hiring him for my pocket.
Some shit I think screwed
dude. What's our, oh,
we're going to get back into Ozarks,
which just came down and
I watched the first two. I
couldn't get into it. No Shit.
No really? But I'm also a guy, took
seven years, get on with game of Thrones.
[inaudible] tried twice. I can't, and
that was strange. I couldn't either.
And then I was denying what happened.
How did you get into it? I don't know.
I would need a show. I was born, I was
like, let me check this shit out. Oh,
I was on a plane with the, the
writers, the creators of it.
I was on a plane and I thought they
were on there from always sunny in
Philadelphia and then went yep,
we're, yeah, we're shooting in, uh,
and uh, Ireland this year I went Ireland,
Jesus always sunny in Philadelphia.
You guys really went Hollywood.
He goes bring it all the way to Ireland
and then the, it's a private plane,
just go sign. They go and we do
game of Thrones, man. Oh Shit.
And I started talking to them and they
were just fascinating dudes. I'm like,
yeah, you give it a shot. And then
it was damn good. Damn good. I saw,
I know it's good. I think it was
the pilot and I was like, man, drag.
And if I am watching this shit time, I
was bro. Yeah. I like his Lord of the
one. I know there's people rolling
their eyes right now being like, Tom,
you fuck dude, I was the same bro. Here's
another thing. I've never seen sopranos.
Now that's my jam right
there. I love that. Fun.
I've watched the whole series twice. Not
the whole thing. How you got to watch it.
And so I've never seen any love
it. No, I don't love it. But I,
I recognized like it is
definitely quality. I mean I just,
I never fully embraced,
I'm not that fond of Italians.
So like I just, you
know, again, your nerves,
I just think they have so much misguided
pride. They kind of just turned me off,
you know? That's fair. Yeah.
Huh. Like you dad said love it.
Do you watch approaches
of Europe? Oh, aggressive.
Totally kidding. Awesome.
That's hilarious.
Things like you'd never think of like
Italians know like the cockroaches of
Europe. I haven't her. Wow.
Wow. See, I'll watch words.
I'll watch like born this way on Tlc.
You seen that?
The kids with down syndrome.
Oh Gee. You watch that.
Why it's, I don't know. It's interesting.
It's like a bunch of kids with down,
when I say kids so you don't realize how
old their somewhere like 40 45 in the
first place. The kids now they're grown
US folks. And this is born this way.
My 90 Day fiance. Oh yeah,
no, we fuck with that. We, uh,
we fuck with a transition. We just
transitioned. TLC was amazing. Which one?
Which one is lessened? Oh,
hold up. It's like when you,
right before you would go Ryan.
Charles Schwab. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's a really about homeboy who was
just married with a girl baby. I was like,
Yo, baby girl. And he's like, it's
like if I shaved and I was like,
I'm gonna just put on a dress.
It was like, I feel like a woman.
And then they go to their friends by go,
Dave is now Dana.
And I'm like, how come? How come people
keep looking like saying that I'm a guy,
they'd be at the nail salon. Yeah,
he's fucking, he's like you dude.
The dress long nails and then
upset about it. Yeah. He's like,
people are saying it was that guy. He's
like the fuck, you know? And I was like,
this is so annoying. And
also it's like, I mean,
I feel like, you know, he,
he went to get that surgery
consultation and they're like, you know,
we can do this to your eyebrows and your
face and all that stuff. Also, it's like,
Bro, you could take the Diet little
seriously. That wouldn't kill either, bro.
Like I would do the Diet
first. That's what I'm saying.
Just from there, it's like,
he's like, he's like, everybody's
like, you look like a dude.
So it's like, you know,
but man,
like c'mon dude.
I mean I go for a morning
run every morning or just
eating crew tons and water.
Dude, that dude, I was in
Spokane, Washington doing shows.
It's taking an Uber like in the
Uber and it's like, I'm like, damn,
that's the biggest girl I've ever seen.
I don't give a fuck.
It's this little shitty Honda,
but it is,
wreck it Ralph and this
Honda fucking shoulders dress
big on. I'm like, damn, her
shoulders are bigger than mine, son.
I get in and turns around and it's like,
this fucking,
you know me with a wig on. But it
just turned around. I was like,
she looked like bill Bellacheck
with a wig. I feel like
when he transitioned and it was new,
it was not a good, it's never good,
but it's like, you know, in
his or her arms are like,
you tell like a little hairy. It's just
like you got to try harder and harder,
but then there's also limited. They're
not even being cool at the gun store.
To me. Yeah, of course. Makeup on.
It doesn't mean like, oh,
it's a check. Like there's
some steps you gotta go nippy.
Amazing. It was like, I'm
transitioning. And then they're like,
how's your transition going?
He,
he handled it the same way that he
does football questions. He'd be like,
it's fine. It's fine. We're playing
the chiefs this week. It's fun.
We've had him on the show.
I mean the clips on the,
we had him on a lot of personality now.
Terrible show.
That would be a terrible show.
Maybe that would be the show.
How terrible can you
imagine if I was gonna say,
Gee, imagine how heartbreaking and
be, you know, you guys have two kids.
I'm not saying I'm against it. All
I'm saying is if my son, when he's 14,
was like, dad, I feel like a girl,
man. I'm a start rocking dresses,
no more football. And it's not
like, like, oh, this is terrible.
Get Out of my house.
But it'd take a hot second to accept it.
I'm not sure. Like Bro, it's fuck am
I right? Suck that doors. I'm like,
gimme a Humean you me the night.
Let me sit on this. Yeah, no,
I'm going to be cool though. Is your
son, he's going to be huge. I always,
when I was feeling bad for these guys
that are just so big and they really are
never going to pass, you know
what I mean? Well, have you ever,
uh, we had her on our show,
Christina back, Kristen Beck.
Kristin Beck. Ready for
this one. So she was,
he previously was a male when the top,
uh,
navy seals in the world. Oh, I've heard
of that transition and do, I'm a woman.
I've heard, I've read about this in
the news, straight up Badass navy seal.
What always felt like a woman.
And then one of her, you know,
Navy seals, he was like, hey,
this way he told him he was a Katelyn have
drinks on my boat. And he's like, yeah,
I'll come over.
You just always come over.
And he left his dress on and he just
said his friend came over who was also a
CEO. It was like, all right, it's
cool man. If that's what you like,
don't let the other guys find out about
it though. Like just do your shit.
But dude on the side, man, it's crazy.
And then now, and we went out to,
went out to lunch after with her and
again it, it's a fucking navy seal,
man.
It looks like and put lipstick on Mascara.
Here's kind of Iffy, kind of macmillan
a little longer dress and just fucking,
he's sold out and like, Oh man, what the
fuck you're when staring. I'm like, Bro,
you shitting me?
Like it's a tough
go man.
With that TV show is that they're makeover
people are in the Midwest and so they
give them these terrible mom haircuts
and like they make them up and I'm like,
come to La Dude.
First of all
right Christie, if
you're not in la, not La,
it doesn't count Bro. Let's go to
Beverly Hills. Right. I do think
it's great. Make over. I mean,
you really should go to one of the big
cities. Don't do it in. You're like,
I want to look like up chick.
It's my first time in New York or Atlanta.
Yeah, I'd go to the best. Yeah. I
mean you can't, you can't be like,
I'm doing my transition in Omaha.
I hope it goes well. No out.
They don't know what they're doing.
Also what you do is just get them
fat injections into your ass. Yeah.
So at least you have a blog asks
you got a dress on a summary for you
transitioning to a woman. I mean, I have
some dsls for lips. Yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah. You're very nice. Head of hair.
But you could grow out your hair. Now.
My hair shave my face though. They got
high cheek bones. He's got good structure.
I know. It's like I got like that scar
tissue. I can remember going to a full,
anyone? No, they're all going to be
big as fuck. Loud ass.
Those nails on his big ass.
It would not be see it all. It's like
sometimes big bitch is just stand out.
Like if you're at the mall
and you see like a six foot,
I feel bad for those
girls to size like 14 ugh.
Damn girl. Yeah. What do you dress?
It looks like they like sewed together
two pairs of shoes for boots, bro.
I just feel bad for him.
I'm like,
you're in front of 421 you know God damn
well there's nothing that fits you and
they're going to do notice that.
You know,
it's funny because you'll
see the big shoes you buy.
It's a big ass shoes and then your,
well yeah. What she's supposed to,
she's six too. She can wear size
fives but where did you get those? No,
I know they run it.
I mean she probably goes to stores like,
I'm not like Shrek, but there's
certain shit like stores I cannot,
I can't even walk in some of your nose.
Hundred percent.
Which ones could you like?
Definitely not go into a,
I can't go into like Abercrombie
and Fitch. That ain't happening.
I can't pack son that I'm like,
do you have a triple x?
Like that's embarrassing. So I don't
do it. Banana Republic, no way man.
J crew's iffy. Some of their
double x is fit. It's the hate.
I hate shopping for shirts. It, no,
I like clothes. I'm saying I, I hate that.
Like my body size is one
where I can walk into a store,
put on XL and it fits almost like fits
big on something and the very next door,
the double XL for just be like a medium.
Like it's always, it's never consistent.
Everywhere I go is, yeah,
jeans, jeans for genes.
That's the worst hang out. It's so hard
to find jeans that fit perfectly is,
oh my God. To find your brand. Do you
think this guy is going to have success?
He decided to not do
the Tinder online thing.
He just posted that one.
We're really only looking
for a girlfriend. This is
not a joke. Great Vision.
Just try Jesus. Tired of the single scene
and hoping to meet the right person.
I'm a professional artist, creative
person. You know who you are. To me,
each and every person's beautiful. Open
to the possibility of the relationship.
Morphine's something more profound.
Here's the thing, this photo,
he could be a nice guy.
He could absolutely tie you up in a base.
He will wear your face. Yeah, you
definitely could just be like,
I like to bash people's knees watching
screen. He looks nice. I actually,
he looks
totally be a mugshot.
Who took that picture? Dude, those eyes
are no one. No one was like, hey bro,
smile.
Look at the,
the width of the eyes open, but
once I like, he's up to something.
He looks like a bank robber.
Okay. Who's crazier though?
This guy or the toothless guy putting
out Instagram videos every week making,
oh yeah, no, that guy is more of a psycho.
That guy's definitely doing a labor.
That psycho just posted.
I don't know where that is.
Not.
The sad thing is some lonely girl
at a coffee shop, so I'm like,
he looks friendly to me quite of course.
Um, no, she's talking about this guy.
You know,
I don't care about race.
That
nasties by that break your heart.
He's just always putting out, you know,
damn well he don't want a black woman.
He's, he's an Arkansas. Think he's racist.
He looks like he uses the n
word every day. Fine. Yeah.
It's like you see a guy like this,
like Bert and you're like,
that guy is comfortable with it and
I don't trust that guy, my card.
You know what I mean?
I'm talking about
you think toothless or oh,
two, two guys. I'll see.
I think flyer guys worse. Really?
Yeah. What's your theory? Go ahead.
Well, go ahead. I think the
flyer guy for him to put that up,
leave it there and then not to
smile or anything. That's true.
It's so scary that show a certain,
he's crazy.
Obliviousness to society and
like, yes, smiling is good.
It brings people in a little warm smile.
Maybe put a some sort of holiday
sweater on. I don't know.
Something or just be online like
why isn't he on? Yeah. Yeah.
We'll find out too much about him. He
didn't even give his name. Well it's,
it's blacked out, but yeah, it's on
the first one of those tickets. Yeah.
These bunnies are cute. This one had
they played with the kids? Uh, yeah.
This one will tolerate everything. Yeah.
To the kids. I grab their ears and see,
oh yeah.
Right place you can go.
Or You could just make love to
someone. Okay, great. I'm Ashley know.
Treat them nicely. That little
stake in a dick suck, bro. Yeah.
They got their way though, your way there.
Yeah. Yeah. It's called process. Good.
The time girls, this guy, no, I
know what you get online to do this.
Just fucking go to the back pages bro.
I mean, what's, what's his problem?
I forgot about that.
Yeah, that's big still.
Sex Trafficking Booman Oh really?
You know, they said it's going to,
I just know they said it's going to
take over a drug trafficking. Wow.
Human trafficking.
That's great.
Now who you think is a kind of bringing
this party. Dot. Yeah. What do you think?
Who's crazy idea? The guy who posts that
sync like that. Take my number. Sure,
sure. I'm looking for a relationship.
The guy with no teeth right there. Okay.
Or Gay? Nope. You won't
believe how good your straight,
you won't believe how good bills your
Dick dickhead become so sensitive that you
don't need me to in this trip.
That dickhead.
This happened down four times.
It's this barely do it. He,
you shoot an enormous amount of very,
yeah. Is he selling something
hot white car. I mean,
he's saying if you smoked meth,
you'll get super hard. That was his,
that's his thing. Yeah. Oh Wow.
But then do you want you to
do math then suck your dick.
I mean he will key he,
he seems like the more,
the most normal three.
He didn't even light himself.
This guy. The other guys at least know it
put bad light. What is this? Right here?
The last time he got off.
Oh, Jesus Christ. Oh,
a couple of days. Wow. Has she ever
have a nice big buildup in there?
Don't you have a lot of
sticky common those balls,
mom?
Mom was
so nervous. Oh, oh the sticky come. Oh,
I'll make you come. I think the the
comm guys in nastiest. You think so?
You're kind of talking about
sucking heads. Yeah, Dude.
Like that guy too. He's uh,
he has a real nice guy cause in
one of those videos he's like,
I'll just let anyone suck my
deck when I'm on Meth. Like,
like it's a gift that he's
offering. He's like, I'm,
I get so hot and horny that anyone who
wants to blow me can go ahead and blow me
[inaudible] up upfront. The other guys
I don't trust y'all feel like that guy.
I feel like that you guys can let me suck
his dick and move about his day. Yeah.
The other guys.
Your safety zone
then have you ever did in my
life and I long face. Hey,
I'm a big get blowjobs and I
tell you what I tell you what,
I'll tell you when I'm so beck
that been hot horny home man.
I let anybody that can get me a book.
Oh thanks man. It's a nice to let
anybody do it. That's nice. Oh Wow. Dude.
You're a good guy. You're a real giving
kind of guy. That's really cool. Yeah.
I think me the ass to sneak into the
bathroom of this restaurant until you,
the stoke the secrets. You know like I
can tell you something right now. Yeah.
That's the weird part.
Pretty, pretty cool. Here's this lady.
I know you'll like this. This, uh,
ladies getting tasered for it.
Cool. I'm seeing this. Yeah. Oh No,
she's not going to what had happened,
David.
Oh,
she farted bed. Did she, she
far during it. Yeah. I didn't
hear it. Yeah, me neither.
I shoes are terrible.
Okay.
That's the worst case
scenario,
lady. Yeah. In front of
everybody. So embarrassing.
Nothing worse, man. Totally far
in front of your lady. Never.
No, you keep it sexy once.
Not once. How do you,
so what do you do when you got bad
farts? What do you do? I fricking,
I put the silence around him
with a pillow or something.
You know what I'm saying? So now
we have a kid. I'd be like, damn,
he smells like shit. Does she
fight in front of you? No. No,
no homie don't play that.
She was sexy man. Shit.
Give it a few years. It's been like
five. Everyone. She had the baby.
She didn't fart in front of them.
When we don't play that.
Did you see her give birth?
So she did a c section.
I saw the c section I have is traumatized.
Um, check back. By the way,
before I forget please.
At the online store@merchantmethod.com
slash Tom Segura,
there should be the new um,
piss on me. Beat me socks.
Oh Wow. That's nice. And
No, a lot of people like this vinyl from
disgraceful is now going to be on sale.
So check this week. I'm
checking on Wednesday, Thursday,
Friday for the new vinyl from
disgraceful. The, uh, the Netflix special.
Love it. Yeah. So check out that um,
both should be on in the store this week.
Somebody added this, I don't know
if you saw it to the CMDB page.
Oh Chef for the movie that I'm
in that's coming out in November.
Instant family that uh,
the trivia item,
Tom [inaudible] who plays Russ in
this film holds the title of us
water juice.
He and his wife Christina Pr,
outspoken advocates for wearing one's
jeans high and tight and his free time he
hangs out with his friends in the four
stroke gang. So really, really childish.
But there's 13 of 13.
Found this interesting.
Really child is inappropriate.
And did you like doing movie stone?
I,
I think it's probably similar to a lot
of people was experience where I had a
lot of fun, uh, working, doing the,
when you're working it's all
the other shit around it.
The hurry up and wait and all
that traveling and like your, Hey,
I'm funny and we need you to come
in Tuesday and you there Tuesday.
And then it's like, what am
I doing tomorrow though? We
are not working tomorrow.
But you're then what
about Thursday?
Well,
Thursday you're appearing in a montage
that should take like 18 seconds and then
Friday you have a scene. You're
like, why can't I arc? Okay.
And then what about Saturday? Sunday we'll
stay here cause Monday we might need,
we don't know for shooting
that thing Monday.
Then Tuesday we're probably
shooting movies to want any desire.
Now. Some people just get
shit. You like Tel Aviv?
I like to be in people's living rooms.
I don't want to leave my house
for a long time traveling lot.
I don't like leaving the gnostic.
Some big movies you did well, yeah.
I mean I'm not like fricking Harrison Ford
anything. Yeah, but you're, I mean that,
I don't know if you can ask collector.
Yeah, yeah. Touch tax collector,
Shai Lebouf David [inaudible]. But what
about the one, I guess that you booked?
Yeah, I can't talk about that.
Yeah. Okay. That one's big,
but it's different because,
uh,
I think coming from the
world of podcasting and
stand up where you're kind of
the director of the ship and
your time, you know, like,
I can't be gone Monday through Thursday.
I have to have these other
shows in those stuff have to do.
So if you're just an actor,
that's fine. If they book you,
you're getting paid your fine with those
dates. But in the world that we do,
you can't leave that.
How are you going to manage all
the other stuff when you do,
let's say the one of these movies
that you can't talk about yet,
but the one I know about,
I dunno.
Do you don't even know how you're
going to do that? I don't know yet.
Do you know if it shoots here in
la? I do know. Yeah, it does. Yeah.
That's a good thing. I did two other small
ones. They shot in La, which was a huge,
huge, I had like two
days. Yeah. Um, but yeah,
I mean if you have all this other
stuff, you'd do it. I mean they will,
they're not going to be like, all right,
cool man. No, that's another thing.
They do not play. It's not like too like,
oh, you're doing that. That's fantastic.
We'll work your schedule around that.
And I know we only had a day.
If you can't do it, can't do, it's
not like that. That's fun to do it,
but it's not like it's your, it's
your baby. Um, yeah. It's Kinda crazy.
Well, I mean, that's
awesome. Are you going to,
are you looking forward to doing more or
do you not care? I Dunno. I Dunno man.
I just go. You just go. Yeah. Just
go for works out great. If not,
it's exciting. So many different things.
You can try out and see what you like.
You try it out. Yeah. See which
lane you want to be in. Yep.
I know you gotta pick a lane. It is, but
it's cool that you can take even true,
super grateful. Yeah. Super Fortunate.
Yeah. All kinds of cool stuff. Yeah. Yeah.
You got to literally try it
out. Try it out. All right,
we got to get running here. Uh,
is there anything else Jean?
I was going to come at you on. Your genes
are very tight and very high. Thank you.
I usually wear a tighter
ones, but really guys? Yeah,
these are a little looser for, I love that
you're into the fashion game. Oh Dude.
Geez. Are, oh, what are these,
do you spend an extraordinary amount
of money on clothes? I typically do,
but then also,
you know I work for problem e like
I work the Emmys for he next Monday.
So you're working the Emmy's.
What are you doing? I do the Po,
the pre and post show. I've done
the Academy Awards, the Oscars.
What do you do?
Fashion part of it both fashion and the
like the commentary on them like no,
I'm not like, oh here we got and will
Smith will. How are you feeling tonight?
So what is it that's like a, there's
like four of us. Yeah, we can store it,
the gang and we like comment on who we
think's going to win for sure and stuff
like that. Oh really? Yeah,
you do love it. So they,
they hook you up with some cool fashion.
Yeah, I get some cool stuff. That's great.
That's great. So what are your jeans?
He didn't tell him. I didn't tell you.
I know these are frame from the La
Company frames. They're very cool.
My favorites are g star. Those are nice.
I have, I have those. Yeah, I have the,
I have a black pair. Nice. Yeah. Um,
our closing song is called sensitive
dickhead. Cool. Uh, by Ryan.
And I think it's that guy to all Italians
are the cockroaches of Europe that,
that my daddy used to say.
Well yeah.
And Gypsy's he hated Gypsies to
Real Dad from where a hungry.
Both my parents yeah. Really openly
talks about the rotten Brohan.
Mulatto had cigarettes. You guys,
I appreciate it though. Yeah. And,
and at Spain they would openly do that.
She'd be like,
keep Donald [inaudible]
always, always, um,
thank you for coming. Thank you guys. And
he doesn't always love having you. Uh,
you can always check out a fighter
and the kid, Eh, uh, you have a,
what's the final of the belt podcast?
A lot about podcasts can be on Bravo.
He's doing the Emmy's. Got Movies.
I'm in Vancouver on the 13th.
What are you doing now? Coover stand
up. Commodore theater out there.
Stand up Vancouver. And then after
that I'm in Chicago. Schaumburg. Improv
Improv is the 20th and the 22nd September.
Don't forget to order the chicken at the
club. Is it nice? It's really good. Um,
go see Brendan Schaub. He's hilarious.
Great Guy. Listen to his shows and um,
we'll see you guys next time.
Thanks buddy.
Hygiene.
That's nice,
man.
Do you start with a template?
Big Dog.
Okay.
I know nine films.
He lives
John Morris.
It's unbelievable.
Yeah,
me too.
Okay.